Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 50. Hurra, 50 mal Chaosradio Express. Wer hätte das gedacht, dass ich das noch mal zusammenkriege, nachdem ich irgendwie Anfang des Jahres irgendwann eine große Pause gemacht habe bei 44, dachte ich, das schaffst du nie. Aber jetzt ist es soweit, am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove und wieder haben wir eine illustre Runde zusammengerufen, bestehend aus Frank, Hallo Frank, und aus Constanze. Guten Tag. Ja, und jetzt haben wir eine neue Expertenrunde zu einem alten Thema. Nicht wirklich sehr alt, aber auf jeden Fall auch noch topaktuell. Altes Thema insofern, als dass uns das schon eine ganze Weile lang beschäftigt. Es geht um Wahlcomputer, beziehungsweise, damit fangen wir an, und es geht im Besonderen dann um eine ganz neue Form von Wahlcomputer, den sogenannten Wahlstift. Und ja, dieses Thema bedrängt uns schon eine Weile und mit dir, Frank, hatte ich ja bereits schon mal einen Podcast gemacht und wir hatten vorher auch schon in dem Monat davor noch eine Chaosradio-Sendung zu dem ganzen Komplex und seitdem hat sich eine ganze Menge getan und darüber wollen wir jetzt erstmal reden, was sich getan hat und dann vor allem darüber reden, was sich gerade so tut. Wo hatten wir denn aufgehört?
Soweit ich mich dunkel erinnere, haben wir damit aufgehört. Der Report aus den Niederlanden war publiziert worden und die Diskussion in den Niederlanden schwappte halt so langsam nach Deutschland rüber.
Also der Report ist die mehrseitige technische Dokumentation, die beschreibt, wie man diese NEDAP-Wahlcomputersysteme auseinandernimmt.
Genau. Das war sozusagen eine deutsch-holländische Kooperation. Die Holländer waren in der Lage, so ein paar von diesen Wahlcomputern zu beschaffen. Dann haben wir die auseinandergenommen, haben die Software darin analysiert, Wanderlage, die umzuprogrammieren und haben am Schluss darauf sogar Schach spielen können. So als Beweis, dass man da wirklich Dinge darauf tun kann, für die sie nicht vorgesehen waren, was der Hersteller dieser Wahlcomputer hier ursprünglich bestritten hat.
Weil er ja meinte, das wären ja gar keine Computer, sondern das wären ja Wahlmaschinen, was ja mal so ein gängiger Term ist.
Es geht darum, ob es ein universeller Computer ist, der eben macht, was derjenige, der die Software programmiert, sagt. Und die hatten halt gesagt, es ist eine dedicated special purpose machine, also nur für diesen speziellen Zweck gemacht.
Ja, und wie wir denn, also diese, diese Schachinstallationen beruhte im Wesentlichen darauf, dass dieser Herr Grönen da, der die Software für diese NEDAP-Wahlcomputer schreibt, behauptet hat, also, dass man darauf Schach spielen könne. Das möchte er doch mal gezeigt bekommen, weil es heißt, es ist eine dedicated special purpose machine. Das ging ja nicht. Und mithilfe von irgendwie ein bisschen Software und einem magnetischen Schachspiel und 64 Eurocent-Stücken, die wir benutzt haben, um ein magnetisches Schachfeld auf diesen NEDAPs herzustellen, konnte man dann tatsächlich darauf Schach spielen. Die Endspiel-Bliothek war ein bisschen kastriert, weil Andreas nicht mehr genug Speicher gefunden hat, um die unterzubekommen. Aber im Wesentlichen konnte man also bis kurz vorm Endspiel mit dem Problem des Schachspielen.
Ja, und das hat natürlich eine ganze Menge Wellen geschlagen. Es dauerte eine Weile, hatte ich so den Eindruck, bis das so richtig als Thema auch erkannt war im Medienwald, bis man so richtig verstanden hat, worum es geht. Wobei Heise ja nun auch schon seit Längerem noch mal so seinen eigenen Privatkampf gegen die Maschinen führt, hatte ich immer so den Eindruck.
Der hauptsächliche Grund ist, dass in Deutschland halt relativ wenig von diesen Wahlkompetiten im Einsatz sind. Also wir haben hier 1.500, 1.6... 1.850 Wahlcomputer und in Niederlanden sind die halt flächendeckend im Einsatz. Das heißt, da gibt es gar keine Papierwahlen mehr oder gab es bis vor kurzem keine Papierwahlen mehr? Da kommen wir gleich noch zu, wie sich die Situation in Niederlanden entwickelt hat. Und hier sind es halt nur so ein paar isolierte Gemeinden, die halt die Dinge einsetzen. Jetzt im deutschlandweiten Maßstab gesehen, also ein relativ geringer Prozentsatz, woraus halt resultiert, dass es halt sehr schwer ist, zu so einem überregionalen Thema zu machen, mit dieser Bedeutung in den Niederlanden, sondern es ist halt meistens eine sehr lokale Angelegenheit, dass es in den Gemeinden oder in den Städten, wo die Dinge rumstehen.
Es ist so schlicht, naja, eine gewisse juristische Fragestellung, weil einfach über die Hälfte der Bundesländer gar keine gesetzliche Erlaubnis hat zur Verwendung solcher Wahlcomputer. Und entsprechend bleibt es immer so ein bisschen regionale Thema.
Ja, aber in Holland war es große Nachricht. Big News.
Also, es gab halt zwei Kommissionen am Ende, also nachdem der…
Ja, Moment, aber die Kommission gab es ja erst nach der Wahl. Also diese Hacke kam ja zu einem Zeitpunkt raus, da waren die Wahlen ja noch lange nicht gelaufen, sondern war ja noch Monate davor.
Genau, also der Hacke lief halt sozusagen in Sichtweite der Wahlen, wobei halt eigentlich einigermaßen klar war, dass es wohl schwer wird, sozusagen mit diesem Hacke die Situation an den Niederlanden komplett zu kippen. Interessanterweise ist sie aber in Amsterdam gekippt. Also die Stadt Amsterdam hat dadurch, dass die spezifische Sorte Wahlcomputer, die bei ihnen im Einsatz waren, die waren von der Firma SDU.
Das waren andere Systeme.
Das waren andere Systeme. Und bei denen wurde halt festgestellt, dass die halt eine elektronische Abstrahlung wie die Hölle hatten. Also man konnte die auf mehrere Dutzend Meter problemlos den Bildschirm halt empfangen. Das waren so eine Touch-Stream-Maschinen, so ähnlich wie in den USA. Und die halt nach einem total bizarren Geschäftsmodell da ausgeteilt wurden. Und so hat die Firma SDU diese Dinge da hingestellt und dann auch noch die komplette Wartung, Auszählung und Programmierung übernommen. Die sind dann sozusagen abends mit dem Wahlergebnis und der Rechnung irgendwie zur Gemeinde gegangen.
Der totale Hölle, oder? Also das war sozusagen so abenteuerlich, dass, obwohl es eigentlich die ganze Zeit um die NEDAP-Maschinen ging und auch die Abstrahlung ja dort ein Thema war bei der Analyse, dass das erstmal den anderen vollkommen ins Gesicht geschlagen ist, weil jeder sofort gesehen hat, oh weia, bei NEDAP, da kann man vielleicht noch drüber diskutieren. Aber wenn man mal den gleichen Maßstab an die anwenden, da geht gar nichts. Das war auch mit irgendwie über GPRS-Daten übertragen und so.
Genau, die haben noch, sozusagen, Mobil von Datenmodems auf Windows-CE-Kisten waren, glaube ich, die Konstruktion. Also jedenfalls extrem abenteuerlich. Und denen wurde halt die Zulassung entzogen, woraufhin dann die gemeine Amsterdam auf Papier gewählt hat. Das war sozusagen der erste große Erfolg für unsere Freundinnen in Niederlanden.
Während der nationalen Wahlen.
Genau, dass halt die großen Wahlen halt auf Papier stattfanden. Und das war halt ein massiver Achtungssignal natürlich für die Presse, weil dann war klar, das ist jetzt mal so richtig Thema.
Wie war denn das Medienecho in Holland? Du hast das ja noch mit einem Auge mitbekommen, denke ich.
Ja, ich war zu der Zeit auch teilweise da und es war halt ein nationales Medienthema. Also halt irgendwie im Äquivalent von der Tagesschau war es mehrmals drin. Es war auf den Titelseiten von den Tageszeitungen, es war an den Meinungsseiten von den Tageszeitungen, also ganzseitige Artikel über das Problem.
Man findet auch kein Holländer mehr, der heute nicht über die Problematik bescheid weiß, weil es halt einfach überall war in allen Zeitungen.
Also es war halt so richtig flächendeckende Coverage, so wie man es halt eigentlich mit unseren Themen sonst fast nie hat. Außer dem Bundestrojaner sozusagen.
Aber das war eine andere Sendung.
Na gut, aber jetzt sozusagen zum Vergleich irgendwie die Mediencoverage, die die da hatten, war halt so Bundestrojaner plus plus.
Man muss sich vorstellen, dass in Holland kaum noch Leute leben, die noch eine Wahl mit Zettel und Stift kennen. Die sind ja so lange gewöhnt auf...
Wie lange läuft denn das da schon?
Sie hatten auch schon vorher Maschinen, also mechanische Maschinen, mit denen sie gewählt haben. Viele haben noch nie mit Papier gewählt, das ist ihnen vollkommen unbekannt.
Und das, obwohl es diese Tradition mit diesem roten Stift gibt?
In manchen Gemeinden ist es halt schon seit Dekaden so, dass Stift und Zettel nicht mehr verwendet wird.
Also da gibt es allerhand lustige Konstruktionen, halt so mit Lochkarten und solchen Sachen. Also da gibt es halt auch so ein... Ich glaube, in Mecklenburg war die auch noch auf zugelassen, also da gibt es so eine Konstruktion, wo man halt so eine Lochkarte in die Kiste reinsteckt und dann hat man halt so Hebel, mit denen man dann halt seine Stimme sozusagen auf diese Lochkarte locht und die dann halt irgendwie dann da...
Die Tradition solcher Lochkartenmaschinen ist sehr alt. Also in den USA wird die auch schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten verwendet. Da kann man schon Werbung aus den 40er-Jahren finden, wofür diese also Lochkartenmaschinen geworben wird und Werbefilme gibt es da im Netz. Sehr lustig.
The Freedom Curtain ist also einer von denen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den schon mal auf Chaos TV hatte. Wollte ich, glaube ich, mal draufschmeißen und dann habe ich es gemacht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, das ist absurd. Also das heißt, diese STU-Maschinen, du musst nur kurz nochmal nachmachen, die haben ihre Zulassung entzogen bekommen von dem Innesministerium.
Genau, also der Innesministerium hat, weil die Einzigen, die in der Lage sind, da elektronische Abstrahlung zu analysieren, ist halt der Geheimdienst. Also, weil die haben halt irgendwie die Werkzeuge dafür und also haben sie halt den Geheimdienst gefragt und die haben dann halt diese Analyse durchgeführt und haben dann halt die Sachen bestätigt, die wir halt zu den NEDAPs gefunden haben. Haben aber gefunden, naja, man könnte die gerade noch so mal eben so durchgehen lassen, weil sind halt nur so 15 bis 20 Meter und nicht gleich irgendwie so richtig die Straße runter.
Man könnte sie ja auch besser abschirmen.
Ja, also die Situation in Holland war die, dass nach den Wahlen halt klar war, so geht es halt nicht weiter. Und man muss noch mal grundsätzlich schauen, was jetzt die Lösung sein kann. Es gab halt zwei Kommissionen. Die eine Kommission war halt salopp vertitelt mit irgendwie, wie sind wir in diese Scheiße geraten? Und die zweite Kommission war, wie kommen wir aus dieser Scheiße wieder raus? Der Bericht der ersten Kommission war halt absolut verheerend. Sie haben sich an ihre Regeln nicht gehalten, alle Tests haben versagt, alle Balancers und Checks haben versagt, sie haben zu eng mit dem Hersteller kooperiert, die Ministeriumsbeamten haben sich nicht dafür interessiert, was die Probleme sein könnten und so weiter und so fort.
Aber auch ganz grundsätzlich die Probleme waren da schon angesprochen.
Ja, also das war halt so der erste Report und dann war halt schon so einigermaßen klar, dass wohl der zweite Report auch nicht viel besser sein wird. Der zweite Report ist dann sehr...
Wer war denn drin in diesem Ausschuss? Also welche Leute haben denn da eine Meinung abgegeben?
Also in Holland ist das ein bisschen anders als hier. Da gibt es ja nicht so etwas wie ein Verfassungsgericht, sondern da gibt es halt so, naja, so alte Herren. Das sind halt so die alten Ex-Politiker.
Elder Statesmen.
Genau, Elder Statesmen. Die haben da halt so eine, wenn es mal richtig schlimm ist, so eine beratende Rolle. Und aus denen werden dann halt so Komitees gebildet, damit sie sich dann das mal so halbwegs unparteiisch angucken und mit der Erfahrung ihrer Jahre halt mal eine Meinung dazu abgeben, die dann auch meistens halt irgendwie von Belang ist so. Und die, also ich habe jetzt die Namen nicht im Kopf, aber war halt schon so signifikant besetzt, so plus halt ein paar Techniker, die sich dazu geholt haben, um halt einfach, also in der zweiten Kommission, was machen wir denn jetzt, halt sinnvolle Entwürfe halt zu präsentieren, so. Naja, und nachdem der Bericht der zweite Kommission dann raus war, jetzt spreche ich mal wieder ein bisschen vor, gab es gleichzeitig halt noch einen Prozess, den unsere hondischen Freunde angestrengt haben, weil sie festgestellt haben, dass die Zertifizierungsunterlagen für die NEDAP-Wahlcomputer in Holland schlicht und ergreifend unvorständig waren, Sachen nicht korrekt zertifiziert waren. Also die hatten nicht mal ihr Paperwork in Ordnung.
Ach.
Also der eigentliche Prozess der Zertifizierung, der ja ein sehr formaler Prozess ist, ist da nicht korrekt abgelaufen.
Genau, also die haben halt zum Beispiel die Software, die halt irgendwie die Auswertung hinterher macht, nicht richtig zertifiziert. Ein Subtyp der Maschine hatte gar kein Zertifikat, weil sie einfach behauptet haben, die ist baugleich, obwohl sie nicht baugleich ist. Und also so richtig so schlimmes Zeug. Und da gab es diese interessante Konstellation, dass die Stadt Utrecht stand halt kurz vor Wahlen und musste sich halt sozusagen entscheiden und hatte halt das Gericht darum gebeten, jetzt mal irgendwie schnell zu entscheiden.
Also eine Eilentscheidung, klassisch. Gibt es ja in Deutschland im Rechtsraum.
Dann gab es halt die mündliche Verhandlung und die Richterin stellte schon halt extrem kritische Fragen und war einigermaßen klar, so nächsten Monat auch ist Urteilsverkündung und das wird wohl schiefgehen für die Regierung. Und das endete dann halt damit, dass die Regierung...
Das ist mal wirklich ein Live-Podcast hier. Klingelt alles live.
Bevor sie halt da das Problem entwickeln konnte, dass sie vom Gericht abgewatscht wird, halt von sich aus den Stecker gezogen hat. Sie haben dann gesagt, als Folgerung aus der zweiten Kommission, deren Bericht halt kurz vorher publiziert worden war, ziehen wir halt mal die Zulassung zurück. Was halt formal dann letzte Woche passiert ist, hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis sich das dann noch durch die Bürokratie gewunden hat.
Also sie wollten sich gar nicht erst in eine angreifbare Position...
Sie hatten halt verloren. Also es war halt offensichtlich klar, dass sie halt verloren hatten und da ist nicht mehr viel zu retten.
Interessant sind die Kommentare, die so etwa eine Woche oder zwei Wochen danach von NEDAP kamen, die man ja auch nachlesen konnte bei Heise, nämlich dass NEDAP gesagt hat, oh wir sind eigentlich ganz froh über diese Entscheidung, weil jetzt haben wir ja einen neuen Markt, den wir mit unseren Geräten bestücken können und interessanterweise...
Pfeifen im Walde, oder?
Genau. Interessanterweise hatten mir ein Mitglied dieser Kommission berichtet, dass nur wenige Stunden nach der Verkündung dieser Entscheidung bereits Konkurrenten von NEDAP angerufen hätten und gefragt haben, ob sie jetzt dann mal Genehmigungsverfahren einleiten könnten.
Ja, die geben nicht auf.
Die geben so schnell nicht auf. In Holland werden definitiv jetzt einige Jahre Ruhe sein, was die Wahlcomputer betrifft. So etwa bis 2009 oder vielleicht sogar bis 2011 haben die erst mal Ruhe, weil der Zertifizierungsprozess dauert ja eine Weile.
Aber was ist denn mit der gesetzlichen Grundlage? Ist die auch angegriffen worden?
Na die ist in Holland so ähnlich strukturiert wie bei uns und der Paragraf, der ist überhaupt erlaubt, diese Wahlcomputer zuzulassen, der hat halt weiterhin Bestand, aber es gibt halt derzeit keine Wahlcomputer, die den Zulassungskriterien ansprechen.
Das wäre natürlich bei uns anders, da ja bei uns vom Verfassungsgericht geklagt wird, da könnte die Entscheidung absoluter sein, würde ich mal sagen. Also dass tatsächlich die Erlaubnis, dass solche Computer eingesetzt werden, zurückgezogen werden.
Okay, dann gehen wir doch mal wieder zurück von Holland nach Deutschland. Insbesondere jetzt auch, was die Zertifizierung betrifft. Die Zertifizierung wird ja in Deutschland nach wie vor im Bereich Geldspielautomaten durchgeführt. Also die PTB, die Physikalische Technische Bundesanstalt, ist zuständig.
Metrologie heißt die Abteilung. Was? Metrologie, also wo es um Messen geht.
Okay, ja.
Also nicht die Meteorologie?
Die Metrologie ist zuständig von der PTB und nicht zuständig ist die Organisation, wo man vielleicht glauben könnte, dass sie zuständig ist, nämlich das BSI, also das Bundesamt für Sicherheit, die sich ja auch ansonsten eigentlich so mit der Sicherheit von Rechnern auseinandersetzt. Aber das scheint irgendwie noch nicht so richtig angekommen zu sein.
Das liegt schlicht daran, dass die PTB ja bis heute und auch schriftlich bestreitet, dass es hier um Computer geht. Es sind Geräte.
Aber das steht auch sogar hinten auf dem NEDAP-Computer, da steht auch hinten ein Aufkleber drauf, da steht drauf Wahlcomputer.
Oh nein, im Gesetz steht, es ist ein Wahlgerät und damit ist es ein Gerät und Geräte prüft die PTB.
Also, das ist super eingerichtet so. Also, gibt natürlich jetzt...
Gab es denn da überhaupt Kontakt mit der PTB? Ich meine, die werden sich doch nun in diesem ganzen Prozess auch mal geäußert haben, in irgendeiner Form.
Ja, sie haben sich in vielerlei Form geäußert. Sie waren ja sogar gezwungen, sich zu äußern in mehrerer Hinsicht. Zum einen natürlich vom Verfassungsgericht. Da haben sie ja eine Stellungnahme schriftlich abgegeben. Aber Professor Richter, der Chef dieser Abteilung ist, hat auch vom Petitionsausschuss des Bundestages ausgesagt und da offizielle Statements für die PTB abgegeben.
Und was für Statements?
Alles ist schön, alles ist sicher. Wir haben sorgfältig geprüft, da kann nichts schief gehen.
Und mit einem Satz kann man sagen, die Wahlcomputer sind sicher.
Jetzt hast du ja schon erwähnt, die Aktivität beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, die ging aus von Ulrich Wiesner, der ja schon sehr früh Protest eingelegt hatte gegen die Bundestagswahl, bei der ja Geräte schon zum Einsatz kamen und seine Argumentation war, wie kann denn das sein, wenn diese Maschinen überhaupt nicht zuverlässig sind und so weiter, geht denn dann die Wahl noch? Das wurde dann irgendwann abgeschmettert?
Naja, er bezieht sich nicht nur auf die Sicherheit. Ihm geht es auch um die Nachvollziehbarkeit und Transparenz. Er hat eigentlich in all dem, was er jetzt ans Gericht geschrieben hat, sowohl nach unseren Gutachten die Stellungnahmen klar gemacht, dass es ihm um größere Themen geht. Nämlich auch nicht nur um Sicherheitsfragen, sondern um die Frage der Transparenz.
Vor allem vielleicht sogar auch.
Also das sollte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen grundsätzlich erläutern, was nun eigentlich das Problem ist, was wir mit diesen Wahlcomputern haben. Im Kern ist es ja so, wenn wir heute zur Wahl gehen in Berlin, wo wir heute noch alles Papier haben, kann man abends zum Wahllokal.
Also falls sie da ausgefüllt werden, dann weiß man schon, weil da ist wohl was verraut.
Man kann also auch zugucken, wie sie ausgezählt werden und man kann sich auch selber beteiligen an der Auszählung. Also man kann halt einfach sagen, ich möchte gern Wahlhelfer sein und ich möchte gerne an der Auszählung mitwirken. Und dann sitzt man da in der Abend und sortiert halt Zettel auf Stapel.
Man kann seine Kinder mitnehmen, weil jeder Kind ab der zweiten Klasse kann diese Prozedere nachvollziehen.
Ja, also das ist halt durchaus sehr plastisch und so. Bei so einem Wahlcomputer ist es halt so, dass die eigentliche Auszählung findet halt nicht mehr durch Menschen statt, sondern durch ein Stück Software, was in diesem Wahlcomputer drin ist. Und dieses Stück Software haben sich dann, wie wir jetzt neulich erfahren haben, genau drei Leute angeguckt bei der PTB. Also nämlich die Leute ausser...
Unabhängig voneinander oder haben die da gemeinsam ein Team gebildet?
Na ja, die werden vermutlich schon in der Abteilung zusammenarbeiten und da arbeiten halt drei Leute dran. Natürlich muss man noch ein paar Leute dazuzählen, nämlich die bei Grönen, die kennen die Software ja auch.
Genau, und wir kennen sie halt mittlerweile auch. Gut, aber de facto ist es halt so, dass die für den Wähler nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist. Also der Wähler kann halt nur diesem Kassenzettel, der aus diesem NEDAP-Wahlcomputer kommt, glauben oder eben halt nicht glauben.
Man kann sich das jetzt praktisch auch so vorstellen, wir haben es ja nun beobachtet in den Wahllokalen, das wird halt eine Minute nach 18 Uhr auf diesen kassenburgenartigen Drucker gedrückt und dann kommt da eben das Ergebnis raus. Dann tackern sie dann an die Wahlniederschrift und Ende der Debatte.
Ja, also es sieht halt aus wie im Supermarkt, sieht aus wie der Kassendrucker ist halt auch genau wie aus dem Supermarkt, so eine Supermarktkasse. Jetzt drückt der Tim wieder auf irgendwelche Knöpfe.
Nein, nein, du darfst einfach weiterreden, ich bin ja ein professioneller Gerätebediener. Das ist auch alles total sicher hier, also da kann gar nichts schief gehen. Ich habe das vorher geprüft.
Ja, die werden meine Bits auch wirklich gut abgelegt. Also das Kernproblem, das wir damit haben, ist, wir können die Wahlen nicht mehr überprüfen. Das heißt, es gibt halt nicht mal für uns, die uns mit Computern auskennen, eine Möglichkeit festzustellen, ob in so einem Wahlcomputer die Software sich befindet, die behauptet wurde, dass sie da drin ist. Die kann uns halt da irgendwas vorgaukeln und halt da so einen Kassenzettel ausdrucken und der ist dann das Ergebnis. So, da ist es nicht schwer, wir haben so eine Software auch gebaut, die halt genauso was tut für diese NEDAP-Wahlcomputer, um zu beweisen, dass das tatsächlich möglich ist. Und am Ende geht halt ein ganz fundamentales Recht verloren, nämlich selbst unter widrigen Umständen eine Wahl durchführen zu können. Also in der DDR war es so, dass die Wahlfeldschung nur deswegen aufgedeckt werden konnte, weil es halt keine Wahlcomputer gab, sondern halt Wahlzettel gab und man einfach in den Wahllokalen stehen konnte und selber mitschreiben konnte, was die jetzt da gezählt haben. Und aus diesen Wahllokalen, wo die Leute halt drin standen, die Sachen zusammentragen konnte und sich selber ein Ergebnis ausrechnen konnte. Nur so wurde halt festgestellt, auf welcher Ebene und wie da eigentlich gefälscht wurde.
Hätten sie schon einen Computer gehabt?
Na ja, gut, ich meine, mit den Computern war einigermaßen knapp im Osten so, aber hätte es zehn Jahre länger gehalten, hätten wir garantiert Wahlcomputer in der DDR gehabt.
Das ist aber auch für eine Diktatur etwa eine perfekte Methode, also auf eine Weise, die das Volk nicht vordergründig merken kann oder vielleicht überhaupt nicht merken kann, diese Wahlen zu manipulieren.
Da brauchen wir keinen mehr irgendwie vom Wählen abhalten und so.
Nee, natürlich nicht. Genau das hat ja mittlerweile die USZE auch bemerkt, denn da gibt es ja eine Arbeitsgruppe innerhalb der USZE, die ODIHR, die sich darum kümmert und sozusagen vom Westen aus, sag ich mal, oder von der ersten Welt Wahlbeobachter da um die Welt schickt. Mittlerweile ja auch nach Holland Wahlbeobachter schickt. Und natürlich hat die ODIHR festgestellt, dass so eine Art von Wahlbeobachtung vollkommen sinnlos ist, weil es einfach nichts mehr zu beobachten gibt.
Es sei denn, man wäre in der Lage, Elektronenfluss mit dem Auge nachzuvollziehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, bisher noch keinem gelungen.
Würde ich sagen, debattieren war in 30 Jahren mal.
Mit dem Quantumfinger. Ja, aber das ist doch ein Wahlcomputer.
Ist die Katze jetzt tot oder nicht?
Also die Sache mit dem Diktator.
Ich will da nochmal kurz einhaken, weil ich sehe das natürlich. Nur die Debatte wird immer wieder geführt um, naja, die sind aber sicher. Da kann ja keiner ran, da kann ja keiner die Software austauschen. Diese Unterstellungen, die Maschinen könnten nicht so arbeiten, wie das irgendwie gedacht ist, die ist ja vollkommen heiltlos, weil wir haben da ja Experten und wir haben Wachsiegel, Prozeduren, die das sicherstellen. Jetzt hatten wir ja da schon in Cottbus unsere eigenen Erfahrungen gemacht. Es wurde, glaube ich, noch eine zweite Wahl beobachtet nach Cottbus.
Im Herbst, in Zeitz, in Bad Eulenhausen und Roslau.
Das ist in Sachsen-Anhalt?
Ja, und in Nordrhein-Westfalen, also Bad Eulenhausen.
Und was kam dabei raus?
Das waren im Prinzip dieselben Ergebnisse.
Kannst du nochmal wiederholen, die Ergebnisse?
Die Ergebnisse sind im Grunde, dass zum einen die Wahllelfer vollkommen arglos sind. Also diese Maschinen gar nicht als Computer sehen, die überhaupt in irgendeiner Weise manipulationsanfällig sind. Dass sie entsprechend auch keine besonderen Vorkehrungen treffen, um diese Wahlcomputer zu sichern. Wir hatten ja nun Systemmitglieder, die ganz alleine waren, mit diesen Wahlcomputern. Einfach weil natürlich die Wahllelfer die Problematik gar nicht sehen. Hatte sich auch noch nicht so rumgesprochen. Des Weiteren wurde auch hier beobachtet, wie die Wahlcomputer untergebracht sind. Etwa mit welchen Schlössern die gesichert sind. Dass nachts im Lager mal ein Fenster offen stand. All diese Dinge. Aber auf diese Art von Wahlbeobachtung, das ist gar nicht mehr der Kern der Debatte. Weil wir wollen eigentlich weg von diesem Außentäter-Szenario. Dass da etwa irgendjemand angelaufen käme und von außen diesen Wahlcomputer manipulieren will. Weil darum geht es uns gar nicht. Wenn man mal auf die Geschichte der Wahlmanipulation legt, die schon sehr alt ist, dann wird man feststellen, dass Wahlen von Indentätern manipuliert werden. Nämlich genau solchen, die ein Interesse an der Machterhaltung oder Machtergreifung haben. Klar.
Also den Zuwählenden sozusagen. Den Zurwahlstehenden.
Leute, die ohnehin schon im Rathaus sitzen oder da gerne wieder hin wollen, oder deren Helfer.
Also es geht gar nicht darum. Und deshalb ist auch diese Debatte um die Prozeduren, die auch zu gutem Zugriff haben auf so Kellerräume in Rathäusern. Also wir wissen aus der Geschichte bereits, dass es eben nicht um diese einsamen von außen Manipulierenden geht, sondern um Momententäter. Und da helfen die Prozeduren, die immer wieder betont werden vom Bundesinnenministerium oder von der PTB, mal gar nicht. Und dieselbe Debatte fühlen wir jetzt immer wieder beim Wahlstift, also beim digitalen Wahlstiftsystem.
Da kommen wir jetzt auch noch gleich drauf. Ich wollte bloß noch mal vorher diesen Blick in die letzten, ja schon fast zwölf Monate richten, die Klage vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht. Was war da jetzt im Mittelpunkt und was ist da bisher bei rausgekommen?
Also Ulrich Wiesner hat sich natürlich sehr auf die Security Analysis aus Holland, die da publiziert worden war, bezogen. Und wir als Chaos Computer Club haben uns natürlich wirklich doll gefreut, als wir wenig später, nachdem die Klage eingereicht war, dann Brief vom Bundesverfassungsgericht bekommen haben, wo wir aufgefordert wurden, ob wir nicht Stellung nehmen könnten und quasi diesen Hack erläutern könnten. Da haben wir uns natürlich nicht zweimal fragen lassen.
Und was kam dann dabei raus? Ein Gutachten?
Wir haben quasi die ganzen Erkenntnisse zusammengefasst, natürlich auf Deutsch dieses Mal, direkt fürs Gericht. Also Frank und ich zusammen mit Rob Gronkruyp haben zusammengeschrieben auf 55 Seiten, bebildert und in einer möglichst einfachen Sprache für jedermann verständlich dargestellt. Wir haben auch durchaus die Wahlbeobachtung einfließen lassen, damit wir also die Prozeduren, die behauptet werden, dort widerlegen. Wir haben uns auch mit den Schlüsseln befasst. Wir haben dargestellt, wie die Tempest-Attacke, also in Bezug auf die elektromagnetischen Abstrahlung, wie die funktioniert. Wir haben also versucht, den ganzen Prozess zu dokumentieren. Genau, denn die 60 Sekunden waren ja dann auch relativ frisch. Also der 60-Sekunden-Hack ist auch so ein Video. Kannst du ja später dann verlinken auf der Webseite, wo man einfach sehen kann, dass in 60 Sekunden dieser Speicherbock steht.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar schon bei ChaosTV draußen.
Kannst du da nochmal einen Link hinstellen?
Ja, wenn nicht, dann werfe ich das eh nochmal rein.
Das ist eine richtig unterhaltsame Sekunde.
Ja, das ist lustigerweise, die Journalisten finden das Video auch alle total toll. Die Hessen-Journalleute haben das auch gleich wieder verwurstet.
Naja, und wir hatten halt ein bisschen Glück mit der Presse, weil wir zum richtigen Zeitpunkt den Inhalt dieser Stellungnahme dem Spiegel bekannt gemacht haben, also dem deutschen Nachrichtenmagazin Der Spiegel. Und ja, einige der Redakteure haben die Präzisions durchaus erkannt und haben halt zum genau richtigen Zeitpunkt einen Artikel dazugeschrieben, weil nämlich, das war eine Woche, bevor der Petitionsausschuss getagt hat, weil wir hatten ja gleichzeitig noch die Petitionen, über die wir noch nicht gesprochen haben, zu laufen.
Genau, bei der Petition ging es darum, dass der Tobias Hahn eine Petition in dem Online-Petitionssystem des Deutschen Bundestages eingestellt gehabt, wo er darum bittet, halt den Paragrafen abzuschaffen, der halt den Einsatz von Wahlcomputern erlaubt.
Also dieses Wahlgeräte, ist das ein Gesetz? Wahlgeräteverordnung?
Nein, das ist ein Paragraf im Wahlgesetz, aus dem die Wahlgeräteverordnung abgeleitet ist. So zu sagen, ist halt der Root of all evil in diesem Fall. Die Petitionsserver waren etwas überlastet. Ich glaube, wir waren einer der top 3 Petitionen damit.
Wir nennen die zweitbeste ever.
Ja, zweitbeste, genau. Die zweithoffigst unterschriebene Petition.
Mit über 45.000 Stimmen, so weit dieser Server zählen konnte, weil er hatte ja einen kleinen Schluck auf.
Ah, ein Computer hatte ein Problem, eine Online-Abstimmung zu zählen.
Das ist selbstverständlich die Ironie des Ganzen, die nicht verbogen wurde.
Es wurde dann eine Ersatzpetition eingerichtet. Möglicherweise haben wir die 50.000 Stimmen ja sogar geknackt. Wir wissen es nicht. Offiziell sind es über 45.000. Interessant ist, dass Tobias Hahn eigentlich völlig unabhängig vom CCC diese Petition gestartet hat, uns aber sehr frühzeitig bekannt wurde über einen Blog. Interessanterweise hat dieser Tobias direkt bei mir gegenüber im Büro gearbeitet. Der ist nämlich Mathematiker an der Humboldt-Uni. Aber das hat sich einfach zufällig ergeben. Wir müssen sagen, dass uns die Blogosphäre bei dieser Petition doch sehr geholfen hat, weil da einfach viele, die sich damit ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt haben oder zumindest die Petition unterstützt haben. Und so kamen wir auf diese hohe Anzahl. Und die Anzahl der Stimmen ist nicht unbedeutend im Petitionsausschuss. Und als der dann endlich tagte, war es genau eine Woche, nachdem der Spiegel rauskam, und alle Fraktionen im Bundestag hatten eine Kopie dieses Artikels vor sich liegen. Wir saßen oben in der Gästelange im Bundestag, haben geguckt, noch gemeinsam mit Richard Siedmann, der Wahlcomputerexperte von Heise. Und wir haben halt die Fraktionen gut sehen können, und die hatten alle diesen Bericht. Und alle haben sich auch in ihren Statements darauf bezogen und haben dann natürlich vom Bundesinnenministerium verlangt, dass die CD, die wir, oder DVD, die wir ans Bundesverfassungsgericht gesendet haben, wo ja einige Filme, das Vorgehen dokumentieren, den Fraktionen bekannt gemacht wird. Die haben also verlangt, dass sie diese Filme bekommen. Und sie wollten auch das Gutachten haben.
Haben sie auch bekommen.
Das ist soweit nicht dokumentiert. Wir kennen nur die Forderung. Wir wissen nicht im Einzelnen, was danach, nach diesem Ausschuss passiert ist. Das ist halt unklar.
Das heißt, das eigentliche Ziel bei der Petition war ja überhaupt erst mal eine Verhandlung zu bewirken. Nicht jede Petition, schon gar nicht jede, die online abgegeben wird, wird auch in irgendeiner Form aufgegriffen. Aber das wurde hier getan, ohne Diskussionen.
Schon deswegen.
Und kam dir da jetzt auch nochmal zur Sprache. Also gab es da auch noch eine Anhörung oder war das nur so, dass Sie sich dann über den Text gebrütet haben?
Nein, die war tatsächlich eine richtige Anhörung. Also eine Ausschusssitzung, wo Tobias Hahn auch nochmal seine Meinung kundtun konnte. Er hat dann ein Statement abgegeben. Er hat auch Fragen beantwortet. Und dann saßen da eben einige Vertreter des Bundesinnenministerium und der Herr Richter von der PTB, die dann die doch eher bohrenden und sehr kritischen Fragen der Berichterstatter, die aus den einzelnen Fraktionen beantworten mussten. Es gibt einen Film aus diesem Petitionsausschuss, weil das ganze Verfahren ist öffentlich und auch gefilmt worden vom Bundestags-TV. Man kann sich das ansehen, denn die Aussagen... Ja, sicher.
Da gab es aber so eine Merkwürdigkeit, dass du eine Weile nicht online war.
Ja, jemand hat den umgerechnet. Also ich kann den in ganzer Verfügung stellen.
Ja, das müsst ihr mir immer geben.
Also es war am Anfang so ein gestreamtes Irgendetwas.
Aber egal, will ich haben. Wird auch gepostet.
Also man kann halt in diesem Film sehr deutlich sehen, an der Gestik und Mimik.
Das heißt, alle Fragen und Antworten sind in der Aufzeichnung drin?
Ja, genau.
Also wer Lust hat, sich diesen Diskurs, der dort geführt wurde, anzuschauen?
Also 25 Minuten oder 30 Minuten, so gerade sehr viel für eine Petition. Und das Ziel von dieser Petition ist am Ende, dass dem Bundestag, also dem Gesetzgeber, die Forderung in der Petition vorgelegt wird. Und die Forderung ist die ersatzlose Streichung des Paragraph 35, die den Einsatz von Wahlgeräten erlaubt.
Das soll jetzt getan werden oder das wird getan wann?
Also mir ist die Prozedur jetzt terminlich auch nicht bekannt, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall demnächst ein neues.
Ja, also interessant ist halt, dass der Thema halt so langsam in den politischen Diskurs rückt. Also, wie ich gerade vorhin festgestellt habe, kam ein Hinweis darauf, dass beim SPD-Parteitag gerade es einen Antrag gab von lustigerweise der nürnbergischen SPD-Gruppierung auf das Verbot von Wahlcomputern.
Tatsächlich? Also ist darüber abgestimmt worden.
Aber ich konnte nicht sehen, ob es jetzt Zustimmung oder Ablehnung war, weil ich nur die Liste der zum Abstimmung stehenden Beschlüsse gefunden habe auf deren Server.
Aber kriegen wir sie sicher raus.
Also die Antragskommission hat empfohlen, ihn abzulehnen. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wahrscheinlich abgelehnt worden. Das kommt auf die Agenda.
Die Grünen haben ja ebenfalls bereits auf den Parteitag beschlossen, dass sie Wahlcomputer ablehnen. Und auch in der FDP gibt es da eine ganze Menge von Ortsgruppen, die sich da gerade stark machen und versuchen, von unten in die Partei hoch da zu agieren. Nur von der CDU haben wir da nichts gehört bisher.
Na ja, das ist auch nicht zu erwarten, meine Internet-Ausdrucker.
Ja, Internet-Ausdrucker werden wahrscheinlich sich mit ihrer Problematik nicht befassen.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich der Punkt. Ich meine, Abgeordnete aller Art schneiden sich ja eigentlich mit der Zustimmung zu Wahlcomputern ins eigene Fleisch.
Richtig, denn es geht am Ende um die Legitimität, und zwar ihres eigenen Mandates.
Ihres Jobs.
Das heißt, wenn man als Abgeordneter dort sitzt, dann kann man nur darauf vertrauen, dass die Bürger da draußen, dass die anerkennen, dass man dort legitimiert sitzt. Und die Legitimation zieht sich natürlich aus dem Votum der Wähler. Wenn aber die Wähler in einer großen Anzahl bezweifeln, dass dieses Votum auf eine faire, transparente, nachvollziehbare, gleiche Weise zustande gekommen ist, dann ist diese Legitimität natürlich in Frage gestellt.
Die sind natürlich so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen. Zum einen ist es so, dass Ihnen die Leute in den Gemeinden erzählen, dass sie gerne Wahlcomputer haben wollen, weil die den Aufwand bei der Auszählung verringern. Und die Hersteller erzählen Ihnen, dass die Akzeptanz von Wahlcomputern dazu führt, dass mehr Leute wählen gehen, was wir statistisch nicht belegen können. Und angeblich sind sie auch noch kostengünstiger. Das sind sozusagen die drei Argumente und die Auszählung schneller.
Es gibt auch noch Argumentationen darüber, dass es etwa Behinderten- oder Seniorengerichter sei, damit Behinderte und Senioren besser umgehen könnten. Das sind eine ganze Menge kleine Argumente, die in der Summe die Kommunen doch erreichen. Man muss sich wirklich vorstellen, dass NEDAP dort so eine Art Lammadeckenveranstaltung machen und die Vorzüge ihrer Wahlcomputer preisen. Und gerade bei finanziell klammen Kommunen dabei natürlich auf fruchtbaren Boden stoßen.
Wir haben den Corpus gesehen, die hatten ihn nun schon beschafft. Zum Glück war es aber so, dass die Stadt Corpus...
Die hat ihn nur gemietet, ne?
Naja, die Stadt Corpus war so dermaßen pleite, dass sie sozusagen unter Zwangsverwaltung steht. Und sozusagen alle Ausgaben in großem Umfang mit der Nästhörenden, was nicht wieder da heißt, Behörde abklären muss. Und nach dieser Aktion dann Corpus mit der Wahlbeobachtung und dem Einspruch gegen die Wahl und unseren Gesprächen mit den zuständigen Beamten und Abgeordneten haben sie sich dann halt entschieden, diesen Kaufvertrag rückabzuwickeln und die Dinge nicht abzunehmen. Also de facto haben wir ihnen halt gesagt, wir werden halt nicht aufhören.
Und da werden wir auch nicht.
Es ist nicht so, dass ihr jetzt irgendwie die Dinge kaufen könnt und dann sagt der Edge und der Habt Ruhe, das wird halt nicht der Fall sein. Und angesichts der sonstigen Probleme, die sie da sonst noch so haben in der Region, dachten sich die Leute, bitte nicht noch eins.
Also die waren natürlich schon ein bisschen genervt vom Chaoscomputer-Kreis, muss man wohl sagen. Insbesondere dort die Kreiswahlleiterin. Sie hat natürlich nicht damit gerechnet, dass da irgendwelche technischen Experten ankommen und ihnen da die Hölle heiß machen. Die wollten halt ihre Oberbürgermeisterwahl in Ruhe und keine komischen Widersprüche von diesen Computerdeppen, wo sie doch ihre tollen Geräte hatten. Also die waren, da wir nur noch in mehreren von diesen Sitzungen dann waren und versucht haben, dort auch Rederecht zu bekommen und auch einen sehr rührigen Widersprechenden hatten. Also derjenige, der Widerspruch eingelegt hat, war auch einfach aktiv dabei und hat dort nach Rücksprache mit uns, aber auch auf eigene Initiative hin sich da aktiv beteiligt. Da waren die echt genervt. Da kommen diese komischen Berliner und wollen uns erzählen, dass diese tollen, effizienten Wahlcomputer nicht so richtig funktionieren. Hat ihnen nicht geschmeckt?
Ist nachvollziehbar.
Es ist halt schon ein Problem für die Kommunen, Wahlhelfer zu finden. Also es gibt halt durchaus Kommunen, die Probleme haben, diese Ehrenamtlichen zu finden. Und versprochen wird ja auch, dass man im Prinzip weniger Wahlhelfer braucht. Wir haben das praktisch nicht feststellen können eigentlich.
Also de facto war es halt so, dass die in den Wahllokalen immer noch Leute vor den eigentlichen Wahlzimmern hatten, die den Leuten noch ausführlich erklärt haben, wie diese Wahlcomputer jetzt funktionieren. Und dadurch kamen sie halt auf denselben, bzw. wahrscheinlich sogar einen höheren Aufwand an Wahlhelfer.
Naja, die waren eigentlich dieselbe Anzahl wie immer. Also es gab so ein paar Probleme, dass etwa manche Wähler, die haben den Eindruck, dass die Wahlleitung etwa nachvollziehen könnte, was sie wählen, weil wenn das Gerät halt piept, dann fragen die sich, naja, wissen die jetzt vielleicht, dass ich jetzt hier die Grünen gedrückt habe oder die Grauen? Also so war das natürlich passiert. Quasi Benutzerprobleme. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, man muss es wohl als gegeben annehmen, gibt es beim praktischen Einsatz keine großen Schwierigkeiten.
Also wenn man jetzt mal davon absieht, dass die Prozeduren, die eigentlich die Integrität dieses ganzen Dings sich erstellen sollen, halt einfach schlicht ignoriert werden. Also etwa halt in Cottbus gesehen haben wir halt, dass die Dinger halt angeliefert wurden an aller Herrgott's früher, bevor der Wahlvorstand anwesend war und beim Hausmeister abgestellt wurden. Und wir haben Fotos von Mitgliedern von uns, die halt dann ja alleine mit diesen Dingern sind in so irgendeiner Schule halt, wo nur der Hausmeister irgendwo rumgerückt.
Aber wir wollen ja nicht wieder auf diese tausendstädte Szenario, weil wir glauben, also wenn, dann waren die vorher manipuliert und nicht nachher.
Genau, also die haben uns halt auch verweigert irgendwie zuzugucken, wie die präpariert werden und wie die Auswertung funktioniert.
Na klar, weil dieser Teil sei ja nicht öffentlich und noch heute argumentiert das Bundesinnenministerium, dass man diesen Transparenz- und Öffentlichkeitsanspruch viel zu weit fassen würde, wenn man sagt, dass die ganze Vorbereitung öffentlich sein müsse. Weil sie argumentieren etwa, naja gut, wenn die Zettel für die Wahl gedruckt werden, sind ja die Wähler auch nicht dabei. Also hier ist die Argumentation, die die BMI heute bringt, schon reichlich Hanebüchen.
Ja, zumal man ja einen Zettel mit einem Blick ansehen kann, ob er in ordnungsgemäßen Zustand ist.
Aber eigentlich wird doch jetzt die perfekte Überleitung.
Das ist eigentlich die perfekte Überleitung. Eine Sache wollte ich noch reinkriegen kurz vorher. Da sind doch im Zuge dieser ganzen Aufregung in Holland Geräte verliehen worden von deutschen Kommunen, die nicht wieder zurückkamen.
Na zwar war die Geschichte so. Diese schon erwähnte Firma, SDU, hat für eine größere Menge Gemeinden, nicht nur für die Stadt Amsterdam, die Wahlcomputerservices bereitgestellt. Nun waren die halt nicht mehr zugelassen. Das heißt, diese Gemeinden standen ohne Wahlcomputer da. Sie hätten aber gerne eine Netzwortalternative, nehmen wir halt NEDAP oder nehmen wir Papier. Und haben bei NEDAP gefragt, ob sie ihnen nicht mal aus der Patsche helfen können. Und wenn dann NEDAP losgegangen ist und sich bei der Stadt Köln 360 oder sowas...
Um die 350 oder 340.
Die gerade nicht benutzt wurden. Die hatten ja gerade keine Malier.
Das sind diese besonders gesicherten Geräte.
Genau, das sind halt diese besonders gesicherten Geräte, die unter versiegelten Bedingungen, keine Ahnung, von Orks in tiefen Dungeons bewacht wurden.
Entschuldigung, das ist ja wohl jetzt zynisch. Natürlich sind die Prozeduren ganz toll.
Genau, also jedenfalls diese Geräte wurden dann, um es mal sozusagen offiziell darzustellen, in die Hände einer ausländischen Macht gegeben. Genau, die wurden halt teilweise umgebaut und mit einer neuen Software versehen.
Weil die deutschen Geräte noch etwas anders sind?
Die haben schlicht eine andere Software.
Aber man hat auch schön gesehen, dass dieser Unterschied, der ja auch lange Zeit immer so als wichtig betont ist, ja ganz andere Geräte, durch ein Software-Update komplett egalisiert werden kann. Dann legt man wahrscheinlich noch eine andere Schablone drauf mit anderen Tasten und so und das war's.
Also, Dieter Richter von der PTB nimmt bis heute nicht das Wort ähnlich in den Mund, wenn er über die holländischen und über die deutschen Maschinen redet. Also, dass diese Wahlcomputer fast identisch sind, ist mittlerweile auch bewiesen. Aber die PTB behauptet immer noch, die seien nicht mal ähnlich.
Genau. So, also jedenfalls diese...
Die wurden dann auch eingesetzt?
Die wurden da eingesetzt und dann gingen die halt wieder zurück an NEDAP, damit sie wieder zu deutschen Wahlcomputern werden.
Wieder ein Software-Update.
Wieder ein Software-Update und halt die holländischen Beschriftungen ab und irgendwie... Und ich glaube, was sie halt noch austauschen, ist dieses externe Bedienteil, weil das hat der Deutsche, hat einen Knopf unten, schlusseschalter mehr oder irgendwie so weiter. Ja, also jedenfalls irgendwie so Knopf-Farben, Größen, so Details, also jedenfalls nichts.
Aber nichts, was man auch so in einem Nachmittag macht, sondern da muss man schmarr.
Das schraubt man halt so ein bisschen so, ich schätze mal, so in zwei Minuten an jeder Maschine schraubt man dann auch die Buttons ab und neue ran oder so.
Na gut, aber mal 360 ist dann schon...
Genau, also jedenfalls standen die Dinge halt in einer Lagerhalle bei NEDAP. Und dann gab es einen, ja, wie sagt man so schön höhere Gewalt, sagt NEDAP, jedenfalls brannten diese Dinge ab. Wir waren es nicht.
Die ganze Lagerhalle, die ganze Produktionsstätte ist abgebrannt.
Also diese ganze Lagerhalle, in der diese Kölner Wahlcomputer standen.
War das die Produktionsstätte oder war das nur eine Lagerhalle?
Das ist die Lagerhalle neben der Produktion.
Man muss sich jetzt schon mal fragen, ob nicht auch noch eine neue Gefahr von den Wahlcomputern ausgeht. Etwa spontane Selbstexplosion im Wahllokal.
Das ist natürlich ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Also stell dir mal vor, Terroristen würden auf die Idee kommen.
Ja, genau.
Also die sind alle verbrannt.
Die sind halt schlicht verbrannt.
Was heißt, die ganzen Wahlen, waren das alle in Köln?
Nein, es waren etwas mehr als die Hälfte, glaube ich. Also in Köln haben sie, glaube ich, 580 und in Frankfurt sind 340 verbrannt. Und dann haben wir statt Köln einen Fax von NEDAP, wollten wir sie in Dristand. Ja, also ihre Wahlcomputer sind verbrannt, war höhere Gewalt, können wir leider nicht zahlen.
Schade.
Das heißt, die Kölner tun NEDAP einen Gefallen.
Haben die dafür Geld bekommen?
Unklar. Also im Prinzip tun sie einen Gefallen. Das heißt, sie entlassen ihre eigenen Maschinen, lassen sie komplett umbauen. Also diese Geräte, die mit Bauart-Zulassung da stehen, das muss man sich auch mal geben, werden dann irgendwie per Post durch die Gegend geschickt und kommen dann nicht zurück. Dann verbrennen sie und dann kommt derjenige, der sich das ausgeliehen hat, der sozusagen da eine Gelegenheit hat, den Markt neu zu besetzen, sagt dann so, ach tut uns leid, es ist abgebrannt, aber ihr braucht die ja sicherlich nicht, ihr könnt ja neue kaufen.
Ja, also es war ebenfalls extrem professionelles Verhalten seitens von NEDAP. Ja. Mittlerweile ist es wohl so, dass sie das bestreiten, dass sie gesagt haben, irgendwie können wir nichts machen, sondern sie verhandeln jetzt wohl gerade über die Kondition einer Ersatzlieferung oder so.
Was hätte ihre Versicherung gesagt, übernehmen den Schaden oder so?
Ja, ich schätze mal, wenn NEDAP auch nur ansatzweise schlau ist, dann werden sie gesagt haben, wir machen Regeln immer lieber selber.
Weil sie haben jetzt sehr, sehr viele tausende Wahlcomputer in Holland zu viel, da wird sich bestimmt was regeln lassen.
Da haben sie jetzt ja, also im Ergebnis der zweiten Kommission wurden ja dann die, also in Holland die Wahlcomputer von NEDAP auch, die Zurlassung umzogen, haben wir ja schon erklärt. Und gerade heute sah ich das Video von NEDAP, wie sie sich die Zukunft vorstellen. Großartig. Und zwar nimmt man halt einen NEDAP-Wahlcomputer. Ist das online? Ja, ist bei NEDAP verlinkt irgendwo. Und nagelt da einen Drucker in den Deckel. Und das sieht halt aus wie, naja, als würde man halt so ein Ding nehmen, so eine graue Kiste und hängt die da so ran. Also da hängt dann hinten so eine graue Kiste noch an dem Wahlcomputer, wo so ein Kabelbaum rausgeht, der dann irgendwann in der Eingeweine verschwindet. Und sieht halt allgemein so aus, so wie wenn wir so hingehen und so einen Prototypen basteln. So, und dann kommt da halt ein, also dann tippt man, wie üblich, seine Wahl auf dem NEDAP-Ding. Und dann ist der statt dem Stem, also dem Abstimmen-Button, gibt es einen Print-Button. Dann drückt man dann drauf und dann kommt dann oben so ein Kassenzettel aus diesem Drucker raus. Und auf diesem Kassenzettel steht halt, was man abgestimmt hat und ein 2D-Barcode, wo halt encoded ist, was man abgestimmt hat. Was für einen Wider natürlich nicht nachvollziehbar ist, weil der hat halt keinen 2D-Barcode-Leser.
Er kann sich auch mal ein bisschen weiterbilden für die Demokratie.
Ja, okay, das ist vielleicht der Argument. Vielleicht könnte er die Bits zählen, meinst du?
Da steht ja nur der Barcode oder steht auch, was er abgestimmt hat?
Steht auch, was er abgestimmt hat. Aber der Barcode ist sozusagen, ob das nun unklar ist.
Ich finde, Wälder könnten sich da bilden und sich mit Barcode, ich sag mal, Dekodierung auseinandersetzen.
Ja, und das könnte man natürlich schon feststellen, ob dieser Barcode was anderes kodiert, als das, was da steht.
Okay, müsste man dann halt dem Wähler sozusagen aufbürden, sein Telefon zu nehmen und damit zu versuchen, zu gucken, ob der Barcode jetzt korrekt ist. Schon ein bisschen heikel. So, dann nimmt der Wälder diesen Kassenzettel und schmeißt den in eine Wahlohne. Und dann haben sie mit Absicht halt in dem Video diese supergeilen, mülltonnenähnlichen Blech umgenommen, die sie halt erdollert, aber verwendet. Die sind halt so speziell konstruierte, mit so versiegelbaren Deckel und so, mit so einem giegeligen Ding. Mülltonnenähnchen. Genau. Das sieht halt wirklich aus wie so eine Ostmülltonne, ja. Also da würde ich auch nicht meine Stimme reinschmeißen wollen. Dann wird die reingeschmissen und dann abends werden die halt da rausgeholt, zu so einem hübschen Stapel aufsortiert und dann in ein Zielgerät gesteckt, was selbstverständlich auch von NEDAP ist. Und in diesem Zielgerät werden dann die 2D-Barcodes wieder ausgelesen und das Ergebnis wird angezeigt. Das ist jetzt halt die tolle neue Verbesserung, die NEDAP gerade in den Markt drücken möchte.
Also sie versuchen jetzt sozusagen dicke Pflaster da drauf zu kleben auf ihr kaputtes System.
Ne, also das finde ich übertrieben, wird das Kind dicke Pflaster.
Das ist halt schon in der Kategorie Atomkraftwerke mit Klebeband fixen.
Also da sieht man einfach auch, wie die Strukturell und konzeptionell diese Wahlcomputer sehen. Da kann man doch als jemand, der sich mit Sicherheit von Systemen befasst, eigentlich, da kann man nur ganz müde lachen.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir ja genau auf den Punkt, nämlich die Sache mit diesem Papierbeleg. Also schon als diese ersten, wie heißen die so schön, Direct-Recording-DRE-Maschinen aufkamen, dann gab es immer schon diese Unterscheidungen in Paper Trail und nicht Paper Trail. Also gibt es einen auf Papier gedruckten Beleg oder nicht? Manche hatten das, manche hatten das nicht. Was ist denn, NEDAP hatte es nicht, will es aber jetzt haben, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Was macht es denn besser, wenn eine Maschine was ausdruckt oder was verändert sich denn?
Also die theoretische Verbesserung könnte sein, dass man hinterher sozusagen per Hand nachzählen kann. Also wenn irgendjemand sagt, ich glaube das nicht, ich würde nachzählen, könnte man sich hinsetzen und die Papierschnipseln nachzählen. Das Problem, was dabei natürlich entsteht, ist, wenn es eine Divergenz gibt, welches Ergebnis zählt. Also wenn wir jetzt fangen wir jetzt zu diesem Computerergebnis und wir haben jetzt ein Papierergebnis. Ein Papierergebnis, muss man fairerweise sagen, ist in der Regel mit einer gewissen Unschärfe versehen. Also es ist halt so ein Papierergebnis, wenn man halt irgendwie so ein Wahllokal zählt, so am Abend. Wenn man fünfmal zählt, kann man durchaus mal ein abweichendes Ergebnis haben. Also es ist halt so etwa die Quote 1 zu 5, so dass man halt sich vertuten Zettel irgendwo reinrutscht.
Und es liegt auch schlicht daran, dass bei Papierwahlen natürlich manchmal einfach nicht ganz klar ist, was wollte der Wähler hier. Die werden in der Regel aussortiert, dass man noch mal gemeinsam debattiert.
Kreuze an der falschen Stelle oder ein Strich oder zwei Kreuze.
Oder wenn es so aussieht, dass er dann zwei Kreuze gemacht hat, weil vielleicht auch irgendwo ein Strich ist oder sowas.
Also da gibt es halt sozusagen immer eine gewisse Unschärfe. Wenn jetzt also so eine Divergenz entsteht, was tut man dann? In Hamburg gibt es ja diese Idee des Wahlstiftes. Da ist die Idee dahinter, dass man sagt, okay, man nimmt ein Papier, auf dem so eine Art unsichtbares oder fast unsichtbares Muster aufgedruckt ist und einen elektronischen Stift, der die Position der Mine auf dem Papier elektronisch erfassen kann. Das heißt, man macht halt so ein Kreuz da drauf und über dieses Muster auf dem Papier weiß der Stift, wo dieses Kreuz sich auf dem Papier befindet. Danach wird dann der Stift in so einer Dockingstation gesteckt, ausgelesen in so einem Computer und gelöscht für den nächsten wieder und die Papierstimme wandert halt in so einer Ohren. Und nun denkt man sich, naja, klingt er erst mal ganz gut. Hat man ein elektronisches Ergebnis, mit dem man halt irgendwie schnell eine Auszählung machen kann, sodass man noch am Wahlamt die Diskussion der Verlierer und Sieger haben kann, was ja irgendwie das warum es eigentlich geht offenbar, zumindest den meisten Politikern. Was auch immer daran so erstrebenswert sein soll, dass man das irgendwie an dem Abweis, voll die Game-Zeit und zum anderen halt ein Papierergebnis so. Nun dachten sich die Hamburger, naja, das könnte natürlich wirklich sein, dass es da eine Divergenz gibt. Soweit gibt es halt bei diesem Wahlstift zum Beispiel eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten, absichtlich eine Divergenz zwischen Papierergebnis und elektronischem Ergebnis zu erzeugen, indem man zum Beispiel einen Stift daran hindert, das Muster zu sehen und man hat trotzdem ein Kreuz auf dem Zettel.
Kannst du vielleicht erst mal erklären, wie dieser Stift funktioniert? Weil ich glaube, das ist jetzt irgendwie vielen Leuten dieser ganzen Diskussion auch nicht klar. Also ich benutze einen Stift und Papier.
Genau, dieser Stift enthält eine Kamera.
Also man muss sich erst mal vorstellen, wie der aussieht. Der sieht aus wie ein Kuli, nur ein bisschen dicker.
So dick wie ein Besenstiel ungefähr. Und vorne ist halt die Mine und unter der Mine sitzt eine kleine Kamera. So, und ansonsten hat man halt diesen Stift in der Hand, der hat noch so zwei LEDs, aber die tun erst mal nichts zur Sache. Soweit jetzt passiert ist, wenn man diesen Stift in die Hand nimmt und aufs Papier setzt, dann schaltet sich die Kamera an.
Das heißt, es gibt so einen......Drucksensor....Drucksensor, okay.
Der schaltet halt die Kamera an.
Ja.
So, und die Kamera erfasst dann das Papier. Und wenn auf dem Papier ein bestimmtes Muster ist, das Muster ist von der Firma Anoto, die dieses System entwickelt hat, patentiert worden, anoto.com ist die Webseite, dann kann der Stift aus diesem Muster, das sind so ganz kleine Punkte in 0,3 mm Abstand, erkennen, wo er sich auf dem Papier befindet. Das sind komplexe Systeme, die haben sozusagen eine große Fläche von so einem Papier, mathematisch errechnet in einem bestimmten Muster, haben die unterteilt in einzelne Seiten. Man kann jetzt einfach mal hingehen, wenn man dieses Anoto-System benutzen will, lizenziert man von denen Papier. So, was diese Eigenschaft hat, dass der Stift weiß, wo er sich auf diesem Papier befindet.
Also man kauft es nicht bei Ihnen, man lizenziert es. Lizenziert es, dass man selber drohen darf.
So gibt es sehr viele Anwendungen, typische Anwendungen sind z.B. Kurierfirmen, die Unterschriften auf Papier scannen wollen oder Formular-Ankreuzungen schnell...
Logistisch ist das sehr viel dabei. Wenn ein Paket kommt, muss man nicht mehr auf diesen blöden LED-Displays so eine Sache unterschreiben.
Dafür ist es halt ein gemachtes System. Man gibt es z.B. auch als Notizbuch zu kaufen. Du kannst einfach das Dreh rumschreiben, das ist ziemlich sexy. Du steckst es einfach in die Dockingstation und hast deine Papiernotizen gleich digital als Vektorzug im Computer an. Dann kannst du sie damit weiterverarbeiten. Ein sehr hübsches System gibt es von verschiedenen Herstellern, Stifte von Logitech und Nokia und Sony. Dieses System ist halt mehrfach lizenziert von Anoto. So, und bei diesen Wahlen...
Lizenziert man dann auch die Software in dem Stift oder lizenziert man wirklich nur das Konzept?
Man lizenziert de facto einen Chip in dem Stift. Also Anoto verkauft einen den Chip, der diese Identifikation der Position auf dem großen Papier macht. Den kriegt man als fertigen Chip.
Das heißt, das ist in der Regel keine Eigenentwicklung? Nein. Oder ist es überhaupt nirgendwo? Überall steckt dieser selbe Chip drin.
Also alle Stifte, die ich bisher aufgemacht habe, steckt genau diese Anoto ASIC drin, in der er halt genau diese Positionsermittlung enthält.
Dennoch sind natürlich die verschiedenen kommerziellen Produkte etwa wie der Digital Pen von Logitech und die Konkurrenzprodukte so ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Aber es sind halt eher so Features, die für den User interessant sind.
Der eine hat halt so Bluetooth, der andere hat keinen Bluetooth.
Der eine hat eine Lampe, der andere hat einen Vibrator. So eine, so eine Sache.
Es ist aber eher das Drumherum. Der hat dieser Wahlstift. In Hamburg ist jetzt im Prinzip...
Eine weitere Inkarnation aus dieser...
Und der hat auch diesen Anoto-Chip drin. Weiß man nicht, kann man davon ausgehen? Ist sicher das?
Also wir können davon ausgehen, weil es gibt de facto keine andere Möglichkeit, so ein Anoto-System zu bauen.
Okay, das heißt, auf diese Technologie hat man Zugriff, indem man sich einfach im Online-Shop mal so einen Teil kauft?
Genau, kostet irgendwie so, ich schätze, zwischen 120 und 120 Euro. Momentan gibt es leider nur die Windows-Version, gab mal eine Firma, die eine Mac-Version machen wollte, aber es leider nix geworden. Aber gut, man kann ihn in verschiedenen Inkarnationen kaufen, so der momentan coolste ist, der von Nokia, der hört nach Bluetooth und kann dann gleich die Striche über das Telefon zu einem Server schicken und so eine Sache. Dann kann man halt mit allerhand Spielkram machen. Gut, also wir haben jetzt sozusagen einen Stift.
Was heißt diese?
Der malt auf dem Papier und der weiß, wo er auf dem Papier gemalt hat. Danach stecke ich diesen Stift in den Computer und der überträgt die Position, wo der Wähler gekreuzelt hat, in den Computer.
In den Computer hineinstecken heißt wahrscheinlich USB.
Genau, USB-Dockingstation reinstecken und ab dafür.
In Hamburgs Fall ist es also im Wahllokal dann so ein Laptop, der speziell dafür gedacht ist, dass er eben an diese Dockingstation, wo dann der Stift reingesteckt wird, rankommt und dann da die Kreuzchen aufzeichnet.
Und dann?
Naja, und was dann passiert ist, man hat jetzt eine Ohren mit Papier, die wird de facto weggeschmissen nach dem jetzigen Gesetzentwurf. Das heißt, die wird nicht weiter beachtet, weil was zählt laut dem Entwurf des Hamburger Wahlgesetzes ausschließlich die elektronische Stimme. Das heißt also, die Software in dem Computer wertet halt aus, wo ist die Position von dem Kreuz und ordnet diese Positionen wahlvorschlägen zu.
Also auch hier, wie in einer realen Papierwahl, kann es vorkommen, dass der Stift mal sagt, hm, dieser Wahlzettel ist kritisch. Irgendwie ist das Kreuz nicht an der Stelle, wo es sein sollte, nicht in der Mitte. Natürlich die Software. Und dann wird etwa den Wahlhelfer vorgelegt zur Entscheidung. Hier ist natürlich von demjenigen, der die Software schreibt, schon eine gewisse Entscheidung getroffen.
Was wird vorgelegt?
Also die kriegen dann ein Bild, ein Rechner. Ach so.
Aber nicht den Zettel?
Nein, die kriegen sozusagen eine Visualisierung dessen. Das heißt also, die Striche, die der Benutzer gemacht hat, werden rekonstruiert und dann wird wieder Striche hingemalt. Und die werden an die Positionen auf sozusagen eine digitale Seite eingeblendet, wo der Wähler sie halt hingestrichelt hat.
Das heißt, auch hier wird nicht der Papierzettel genommen, dass man mal gucken kann, wie der Strich jetzt wirklich ist?
Nein.
Na könnte man ja auch nicht, weil der natürlich in jeder Weise unnügend ist. Du weißt ja nicht, welcher Zettel es gewesen wäre.
Die sind ja alle gemischt in der Urne.
Weil du kannst dann natürlich nicht mehr zuordnen, welcher Wähler es dann war.
Ja, also du kannst sozusagen den digitalen Zettel und den Papierzettel.
Also wenn man weiß, dass die digitale Auswerbung shady ist, dann wird das dadurch korrigiert, indem man sich das digitale noch mal genauer anschaut, aber nicht das, was eigentlich gemalt wurde.
So ist es.
Richtig, aber dazu kommt natürlich noch was. Denn die Software entscheidet darüber, welcher von diesen Wahlzetteln strittig ist. Hier ist also natürlich auch schon software-seitig eine gewisse Entscheidung getroffen. Ich sage mal, ab welcher prozentualen Abweichung von dem Kreis, wo man ein Kreuz reinmachen soll, dem Wahlhelfer vorgelegt wird zur Personalentscheidung. Und die Software bietet auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen, man kann skippen quasi. Das hat auch eine Sache, wo wir gedacht haben, wie bitte?
Na, aus den Veröffentlichungen des Hamburger Senats und aus den Antworten auf Kleine Anfragen und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist eine Menge Dinge, die schon sozusagen auf der Grundlinie an diesem System halt, selbst wenn man jetzt mal nicht mal Böswilligkeit oder Wahlfälschung unterstellt, also das Thema hat einfach eine große Anzahl von…
Fassen wir das noch mal zusammen. Also das normale Ankreuzen von Kästchen auf ein Blatt Papier wird ersetzt durch das Ankreuzen von Kästchen auf ein Blatt Papier, was aber ein spezielles Blatt Papier ist, sodass dieser Stift noch eine Kamera dazubekommt. Und in dem Moment, wo ich das Kreuz mache, meint er zu wissen, wo ich immer ein Kreuz gemacht habe.
Das trifft doch in der Regel zu. Also das ist recht zufällig, das System.
Ja gut, aber was die Kamera liest, aber nur die Punkte.
So ist es.
Die sieht aber nicht die Farbe. Das ist nicht so, dass ich da einen Strich mache und dann sieht die Kamera die Farbe und scannt das, sondern…
Die Kamera ist eine Infrarot-Kamera und die filmt auch nicht den Strich. Also die ist optisch so ausgerichtet, dass sie sozusagen den Bereich hinter dem Strich, den man malt, filmt und weiß, um wie viel die Mine versetzt ist.
Und kann man mit diesem Stift einen Strich machen, ohne dass die Kamera das merkt? Ich meine, wenn ich so einen Kugelschreiber so locker in die Hand nehme und so ein bisschen über ins Papier gleiten lasse, ohne Druck auszuüben, hat der ja auch schon einen Strich.
Korrekt. Also wenn du den Stift so aufsetzt, dass der Druckkontakt nicht kommt, geht die Kamera schlicht nicht an.
Na, du kannst es doch zuhalten.
Genau, du kannst die Kamera zuhalten, noch eine Möglichkeit.
Ah.
Und du kannst natürlich auch das für den nächsten Wähler einfach versauen, indem du einfach, und dann kannst du den Tropfen Sekundenkleber über diesen Druck-Sensor spritzen, die Mine wieder reinstecken in den Kugelschreiber und dann geht der Druck-Sensor nie wieder an.
Oder beim Edigen auf die Kamera.
Oder beim Edigen auf die Kamera. Es gibt tausend Möglichkeiten, das sozusagen zu sabotieren.
Also wenn man sich die Hardware betrachtet, ist es natürlich so, dass man quasi einen Teil dieser ganzen computerisierten Wahl dem Wähler in die Hand gibt. Der einfachste Hack ist natürlich für den Wähler, dass er seinen mitgebrachten Kuli benutzt, den er vielleicht schon seit 25 Jahren zum Wählen nimmt und diese komische digitale Dinge beiseitelässt. Damit hätte er eine gültige Stimme abgegeben, nicht aber in Hamburg. Denn Hamburg sagt, offensichtlich mit einem anderen Kugelschreiber abgegebene Stimmen werden gar nicht gezählt. Die sind als ungültig gewertet. Und hier ist natürlich auch gleich eine verfassungsrechtliche Frage, weil mehrere Verfassungsrechte haben bereits gesagt, so kann das eigentlich auch grundgesetzlich nicht durchgehen.
Also, wenn man dazu wissen muss, es gibt in Hamburg halt so ein merkwürdiges Phänomen, und zwar den Wahl-Montblanc. Es gibt halt offensichtlich so in Kreisen der etwas wohlhabenderen Bürger Leute, die haben halt ihren Wahl-Füller, den sie halt seit irgendwie mehreren Jahrzehnten nur rausholen, wenn es ans Wählen geht.
Es gibt übrigens noch andere Kugelschreiber-Firmen als Montblanc.
Okay, also gut, jedenfalls einen teuren, edlen Kugelschreiber oder Füller, den sie halt genau dann rausholen, wenn sie halt irgendwie zur Wahl gehen und dann genau dafür benutzen.
So wie der Sonntagskirchentest.
Ja, genau. Und sie haben bestimmt auch ihr Jackett dafür.
Genau, und wenn ich jetzt jemand erzählen möchte, dass sie die nicht verwenden dürfen, sondern so einen besenstieldicken, komischen Plastikkugelschreiber verwenden müssen.
Von dem die komischen Hacker auch noch sagen, der sei nicht sicher.
Also wir haben da lustige Verbündete aus extrem unerwarteter Ecke gefunden in Hamburg.
Okay, aber jetzt wollte ich noch mal kurz, ich liebe die Zusammenfassung. Also die normale Wahl, wie sie alle kennen, wird ersetzt durch einen Kamerastift, der die Bewegung in dem Moment, wo ich den Stift genug herunterdrücke, so mitführt, dass er dann ein Muster auf dem Blatt Papier erkennt und das wiederum als den eigentlichen Kreuzigungsvorgang leutet. So, das speichert er dann in diesem Stift und wenn ich die Wahlkabine verlasse, gibst du den Stift vorne ab, steckst ihn selbst in die Dockingstation. Das heißt, der Stift wird in dem Moment dann schon ausgelesen.
Genau, dann wird er gelöscht, damit nur eine Stimme sozusagen gibt, was immer drin ist, und geht dann an den nächsten Wähler.
Also wird gelöscht heißt, der Computer sagt dem Stift, dass er sich löschen soll?
Ja, es ist eine Flasche, also wird als gelöscht markiert, ja.
Und außerdem ist dann auch sozusagen der Zeitpunkt der Wahl dann auch genau erfasst?
Nein, das ist sozusagen an der Modifikation, die sie gegenüber dem Standardanotostift machen. Also was sie zumindest sagen in der Kleine Anfrage, dass nämlich sozusagen die Echtzeit-Uhr aus dem Stift heraus operiert wurde. Das heißt also, dass der Stift nicht mehr die Uhrzeit... Weil es die späteste ist. Also normalerweise, dass das zu jedem Aufsetzen des Stiftes eine Uhrzeit mitgeloggt wird. Das kann man dann auch normalerweise in der Software sehen und genau diese Funktion soll halt da ausgebaut sein.
Wir vermuten auch nicht, dass sie so einen brachianen Fehler gemacht haben, weil hier geht es natürlich auch darum, ob man die Stimme dem weder zuordnen kann. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz, eine Basissache, die man zunächst mal daraus operieren muss.
Also die, was man halt sagen muss, ist, die versuchen das halt richtig zu machen, so wie sie es halt verstehen. So, also die haben halt einen sehr großen Aufwand getrieben. Sie haben sich halt vom Bundesamt für Sichende Informationstechnik, da kommt die wieder rein, ein Schutzprofil nach Common Criteria, ihr L3 erstellen lassen.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Zertifizierungsstandard für IT-Sicherheit, der eigentlich dafür da ist, sozusagen bei so Software oder Systemen sicherzustellen, dass die Leute keinen groben Bullshit gebaut haben. Also das ist halt nicht irgendwie ein Standard, wo man sagen kann, es ist sicher, sondern der Standard ist halt so ein typischer Checkbox-Standard, so hat Maßnahmen sowieso ergriffen.
Diese 9.000.
Ja, kommt so aus derselben Denkrichtung.
Das heißt, man hat also viele Seiten an Anforderungen, die man dann sequenziell durchgeht und checkt.
Genau, es sind halt so abstrakte Anforderungen, so ist eine Maßnahme gegen diese bedrohenderen Checkmark. Es wird nicht getestet, ob diese Maßnahme auch hilft, sondern es wird halt der Check gemacht, ob diese Maßnahme drin ist. Der Prozessfokus ist dann folgendermaßen, PSI zertifiziert ein Sicherheitsprofil, das hat, glaube ich, die Frauenhofer am Ende gemacht. In diesem Sicherheitsprofil steht drin, okay, für diese Bedrohungsanforderungen müssten wir diese Maßnahmen erstellen. Guckt PSI drauf, sagt, naja, wird wohl so grob stimmen, macht da ein Stempel drauf. Und dann geht dieses Sicherheitsprofil an eine Firma, in diesem Fall ist die Datenschutz Nord GmbH in Bremen, und die nimmt sich dann halt dieses Wahlstiftsystem und vor allen Dingen die Dokumentation, viel wichtiger als das Thema Dokumentation in diesem Fall, und geht halt durch und guckt, ob die alle checkt und stellt Fragen, wenn das halt nicht so ist.
Damit müssen sie sich natürlich jetzt ein bisschen beeilen für Hamburg, weil die Wahl rückt ja nahe und sie müssen eigentlich jetzt langsam an diese Deschottrophie durchkriegen, sonst wird es alles ein bisschen knapp mit dem Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Was heißt, sie müssen das durchkriegen?
Also der Punkt ist halt, dass diese Zertifizierungsprozess halt so formale Anforderungen hat. Also das ist halt nicht so, dass sie da, wie bei uns halt, irgendwie in eine Gruppe Hacker mit ein bisschen Pizza sitzt und irgendwie sagt, jetzt machen wir das mal kaputt. So und kriegt es natürlich auch kaputt, wie das halt immer so ist. Sondern es ist halt so ein formaler Prozess mit so Komitees und draufgucken und Stempel draufmachen und Checkmarks machen.
Und unsere PTB ist auch wieder dabei, denn die PTB guckt natürlich, ob diese Systeme auch robust sind. Die Sicherheit wurde ihnen jetzt hier nicht mehr ans Herz gelegt.
Ach so, an dieser Stelle ist jetzt die BSI auch wirklich die prüfende Behörde sozusagen.
Nein, die BSI ist nur die zertifizierende Behörde. Also das BSI sozusagen, also der Unterschied ist folgender. Das BSI sagt nicht, das ist sicher, sondern das BSI sagt, das entspricht den formalen Anforderungen, die diesem Zertifizierungsprotokoll entsprechen.
Und mehr würden die auch niemals zugeben, weil die natürlich genau wissen, wofür diese Common Criteria-Schutzprofile gemacht sind.
Also sie definieren einmal ein grundsätzliches Vorgehen. Das betrifft aber schon jetzt den ganzen Ablauf der Wahl?
Nein, das betrifft sozusagen nur die technische Sicherheit eines ausgewählten Sets von Dingen. Also sprich dem Wahlstift und der Software, der auf diesem Computer läuft, so ganz grob. Und der Datenbank dahinter. Es wird zum Beispiel nicht betrachtet, das Betriebssystem auf dem Computer.
Und welches Betriebssystem läuft auf diesem Computer?
Nach dem, was wir momentan wissen, XPSP2.
Das ist ja sicher.
Genau. Hat lustigerweise auch eine kommunikative ERL4-Zertifizierung. Eine Stufe höher als der Hamburger Wahlstift.
Hast du noch Fragen über das Schutzprofil?
Okay, alles klar. Also diese Dinger sind nach einem Schema als sicher markiert.
Genau.
Nachdem man auch Windows als sicher markieren kann.
Genau, Windows hat eine höhere Schutzstufe. Achso, na dann ist es eher das 4 und der Wahlstift hat eher das 3. 3 plus, oder?
Okay, also noch mal zurückspulen. Also ich gehe in diese Wahlkabine, ich wähle mit diesem Gerät. Der Stift weiß, was ich gewählt habe. Ich gehe wieder raus, der Stift kommt in diese Box. Dann ist ein Windows-Computer, der liest ein USB-Gerät aus. Dieses Gerät sagt, meiner Meinung nach wurde das gewählt. Dann wird das gespeichert.
Nein, nein, der Stift sagt, meiner Meinung nach hat der Wähler den Stift dort und dort aufgesetzt und kreuzgemacht.
So, das geht in diesen Komputer. Sagt der Stift wirklich, da ist ein Kreuz gemacht worden, oder sagt er nur, ich habe hier so Linien und jetzt kannst du mal nachrechnen, ob das ein Kreuz ist?
Der Stift sagt, ich habe Linien von Koordinator A nach Koordinator B. De facto ist es ein SVG-Fall.
Ah, okay, das heißt, der ist relativ blöd. Der speichert nur, was er sieht.
Ja, das genügt aber im Prinzip, wenn da die kleinen Probleme am Rande nicht werden, ist das schon eine Idee, die funktioniert. Also für einen privaten Anwender ist diese Mustererkennung total perfekt. Also, es funktioniert.
Ja, also man kann damit auch prima scribbeln und so malen und so.
Na gut, man versucht ja nur so ein bisschen auseinanderzuklampen, büsern, welcher Teil sich hier um was kümmert.
Also der Stift tut sozusagen Vektoren in diesen Computer über ein proprietäres USB-Protokoll, was von einem Treiber, der von Anoto geliefert wird, da reingeschoben wird. Dieser Treiber macht daraus einen SVG-File.
Das heißt, es gibt Binaercode, der von der Firma Anoto für Windows bereitgestellt wird und der lädt wiederum Code in den Stift?
Nee, der lädt den Kram aus dem Stift runter. Also der ist sozusagen das Interface zum Stift.
Aber das heißt, diese Software, die den Stift ausliest, liegt gar nicht im Source-Code vor?
Das war zumindest bisher unser Erkenntnis. Jetzt haben die Hamburger bestritten und haben gesagt, sie haben den im Source-Code vorlegen.
Es ist jetzt sowieso die Rede davon, wie wir jetzt gehört haben aus Hamburg, dass sie eher wegen, da noch ein bisschen mehr offen zu legen. Es geht ja immer wieder um die Frage, die wir schon bei NEDAP hatten. Inwiefern sind die Geschäftsgeheimnisse der herstellenden und programmierenden Firmen betroffen? Also im Fall von NEDAP, NEDAP und Gröndal und hier die Firma Halbach. Ich habe vergessen, wie die noch heißt. In diesem Fall geht es ja immer um die Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnisse und ob die höherwertig sind diesem Öffentlichkeits- und Transparenzinteresse der Wähler. Und auch hier ist es wieder strittig in Hamburg. Aber bisher waren einige Nachrichten zu hören, dass sie da mehr offenlegen wollen als bisher.
Genau, was man in Hamburg so gut erhalten muss, ist, dass sie es ernsthaft probieren. Es ist nicht so, dass diese PTB nicht so einfach weggeht, sondern sie haben versucht, uns ein bisschen einzubinden. Sie wollten gerne, dass wir in ihrem komischen Fachausschuss mitarbeiten, dafür hätten wir halt einen Mollkopfvertrag unterschreiben müssen, dass wir nichts sagen, was da drin passiert.
Ein NDA.
Genau, de facto.
Das ist natürlich für den CCC ein No-Go.
Genau, wir haben ihnen halt gesagt, gebt uns ein System und dann gucken wir uns mit anderen Publizieren, was wir finden.
Das haben wir ihnen mehrfach geschrieben.
Das gab aber das Statement, dass der CCC nicht kooperationswillig sei.
Das ist also Quatschschirm. Wir wollten nicht zu deren Bedingungen kooperieren. Das war halt nicht Kooperation, so will ich betrachtet haben.
Ich muss aber noch mal kurz auf die PTB zurück. Die PTB sagt eigentlich nicht, geht weg ihr blöden Hacker. Die PTB sagt, unsere Computer sind zwar nicht sicher, unsere Wahlgeräte, aber wir haben ja Prozeduren, die sie sicher machen.
Das ist jetzt ihre Ausrede, die sie jetzt haben. Also letztendlich ist es halt in Hamburg so, dass dadurch, dass sie es halt eigentlich ernsthaft versuchen, stoßen sie halt an Grenzen. Nämlich die Grenzen sind halt, es hat noch niemand getan. Es gibt halt keinerlei, wie auch immer geartete sinnvolle Regeln, auch international nicht, wie man halt so ein Wahlcomputer so designen könnte, dass er vom Wähler verifizierbar ist, zertifiziert werden kann und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt halt ganz grundlegende Probleme, also zum Beispiel so eine Zertifizierung, so eine Common-Kriteria-Zertifizierung. Wenn man die in sechs Monaten durch hat, dann bricht man schon alle Rekorde, die je für so eine Zertifizierung gemacht wurden. Also dieser Wahlstift wird wahrscheinlich das am schnellsten zertifizierte Projekt in Deutschland überhaupt sein. Typischerweise dauert die 12 bis 18 Monate so eine Common-Kriteria-Zertifizierung.
Aber die dahinterliegende Frage, ob dieses Schutzprofil überhaupt geeignet ist, um irgendwas über die Sicherheit dieses Wahlstiftes auszusagen, die ist gar nicht gelöst. Also neben dem Zeitdruck, den sie jetzt ja ohnehin haben.
Warte mal, wo ich hinaus wollte mit dem Zeitdruck war. Das Problem, was daraus entsteht, ist, wenn man diese Software anfasst, die einmal zertifiziert ist, dann verliert sie ihre Zertifizierung. Das heißt also, wenn die jetzt hingehen müssen, vier Wochen vor der Wahl, sagen wir mal, wie vier Wochen vor der Wahl, sind wir halt mal so fies und publizieren halt immer noch zwei, drei lustige Angriffe gegen das System, dann müssen die ja ihre Software fixen, wenn sie nicht riskieren wollen, dass diese Angriffe durchgehen. So. Und das können sie aber nicht, weil dann die Software nicht mehr zertifiziert ist und sie dürfen sie halt nicht mehr einsetzen. Das ist ungefähr so, als wenn du einen Firewall-Update vor deiner Nase hast und darfst das nicht einsetzen, auch wenn du weißt, dass dir irgendwie gerade er helfen wird, irgendwie nicht deine Kiste abgeschossen zu bekommen, weil er ist halt leider nicht zertifiziert. Das ist halt das Grundübel von all diesen Zertifizierungsprozessen, dass wenn es halt keine Möglichkeit gibt, schnell mal Änderungen nachzuzertifizieren, die gibt es halt schlicht nicht. Das dauert halt immer mindestens Monate, dann ist das halt einigermaßen sinnlos. Also diese ganze Dynamik von Angriffsentwicklung kann mit so einem Zertifizierungsprozess nicht berücksichtigt werden.
Das ist eigentlich die grundsätzliche Kritik, die man auf NEDAP in gleicher Weise beziehen kann, nämlich dass diese sehr langwierigen Genehmigungs- und Zertifizierungsprozesse, dass man die einfach überhaupt nicht mit der realen Welt von Leuten, die sich mit IT-Security und generell mit Computersicherheit befassen, überhaupt nicht. Das matcht überhaupt nicht.
Das ist so, haben sie einen 27b-6 irgendwie, möchte jetzt irgendwie mal die Scheiße abstellen, aber man darf nicht, weil man sich das nicht im Formular unterschrieben hat.
Genau. Also wie gesagt, es ist halt so ein bisschen bedauerlich, dass sozusagen die Hamburg jetzt unter so einem Zeitdruck da agieren müssen, dass sie sich halt einfach da jetzt auch verrannt haben.
Wann ist denn die Wahl?
Die war es am 28. Februar. Februar, die ist glaube ich direkt klar.
Die haben sich nicht mal kommentiert haben.
Ach, haben sich die bloß nicht gegeben.
Die Geräte sind noch gar nicht da.
Also es gibt sozusagen so Prototypen, die wir irgendwie da auch sehen werden. Es gibt da so Schnupperwahl-Lokale, wo man schon mal hingehen kann, das mal beschnuppern kann, das System.
Sie machen eine große PR-Werbe.
Und in Hamburg rühren sie halt die große Werbetrommel. Deswegen haben die sich jetzt auch in so eine Position manövriert, wo sie halt eigentlich schwer zugeben können, dass es halt nicht geht. Was jetzt halt anfängt, ist halt so, die politischen Parteien werden jetzt gerade nervös. Nach dem Hack, den wir da letzte Woche gezeigt haben, ist es halt so, dass wir jetzt Anfragen von so fast allen politischen Parteien in Hamburg kriegen, ob man nicht mal reden kann.
Und da sind ja nun auch noch ein paar Millionen Euro, die da ja bereits investiert wurden.
Na gut, Hamburg, es reicht.
Was ist denn da passiert? Also welchen Hack meinst du jetzt?
Und was ist da passiert? Da war so, dass es eine Beratung gab, wo wir den Grünen einen präparierten Wahlstift zur Verfügung gestellt haben, der halt ein Programm auf einem Windows-Computer über das USB-Interface startet. Da steckst du halt diesen Wahlstift da rein und der explodiert halt ein Loch in dem USB-Subsystem von diesem Windows.
Das war aber jetzt nicht exakt derselbe Stift, der da jetzt bei der Wahl zum Einsatz kommt, sondern etwas Ähnliches.
Wir haben halt sozusagen so einen Anoto-Stift genommen und halt einen normalen Windows-Computer.
Also ähnlich, so ähnlich wie wir eben vorhin besprochen haben, dass sie alle ähnlich sind.
Genau.
Also absolut nachvollziehbar, dass das bei dem anderen Modell im Prinzip genauso funktionieren könnte.
Genau, das haben sie dann halt natürlich sofort unmüllbar wie im Moment bestritten gesagt. Das kann ja gar nicht sein, weil unser Laptop ist ja sicher.
Und außerdem haben ja unsere Wahlstiften, Nummern, die wir uns natürlich auch alle rausgeschrieben haben, damit wir natürlich wissen können, dass da nicht jemand eine fremde Hardware mitbringt.
Genau. Also es ist halt so, sie behaupten halt, sie hätten halt alles im Griff, de facto. Und das Problem, in dem sie halt laufen, ist halt, sie sind jetzt halt schon echt nervös geworden. Also weil in Hamburg ist halt die Stimmung nicht gut, so also gegenüber diesem Wahlstift. Also die Presse lief sehr stark in unsere Richtung.
Wir haben einfach auch mal hingehört, was wir für Argumente hatten.
Und wie gesagt, jetzt wollen eigentlich fast alle politischen Parteien mal reden, was wir jetzt auch machen werden, also mit denen mal sondieren, wie halt bei denen jetzt so die Bedürfnislage ist. Und am 9. gibt es eine de facto finale Anhörung, nämlich eine Sachverständigenanhörung vor dem Verfassungsausschuss, der sozusagen die finale Instanz da ist, wo wir auch eingeladen werden, um sozusagen unsere Argumente noch mal vorzubringen.
Also der Prozess ist halt jetzt so super knapp von der Zeit, deswegen sind natürlich in besonderer Weise nervös. Klar ist natürlich jetzt von unserer Seite, dass wir ja, man muss sagen, dutzende Ideen haben, welche praktischen Hacks wir da noch zeigen können. Und wir können uns quasi einen aussuchen, den wir ihnen da kredenzen. Und wir können aber auch noch warten und also den Februar und die Wahl herankommen lassen. Im Prinzip haben die wenig Chancen. Der einzige Ausweg, der sich in Hamburg noch ergibt, wenn sie nicht die Millionen in die Tonne treten wollen, die sie da investiert haben, besteht darin, dass sie diese Systeme als reine Zehlsystem nehmen. Dass also weiterhin der Papier-Wähler-Wille gezählt wird, also auf dem tatsächlichen Stück Papier. Und dieses nur als Zehlhilfe benutzt wird, damit ein Vorläufer ihr Ergebnis bringt, aber jeder einzelne Zettel gezählt wird. Und das ist auch der einzige Weg, den Verfassungsrecht dafür gangbar halten.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch dadurch schwierig, dass ja nicht nur das neue System eingeführt wird, sondern auch noch ein komplett neues Wahlschema zum Einsatz kommt.
Also das Wahlrecht, was sie halt haben, erhöht halt schon den Auszählungsaufwand.
Das ist dieses kumulieren, panaschieren mit Tralala. Man kann für mehrere Abgeordnete reden.
Sie haben halt, die haben halt da so ein Buch, und du hast halt mehrere Stimmen, und du kannst die häufeln.
Ein Wahlbuch.
Ein Wahlbuch oder ein Wahlbuch?
Ein Wahlbuch. Also im Endeffekt hast du nicht drei Zettel, du hast halt ein Wahlbuch.
Es hat Wahlen nach Zahlen.
Das heißt, man kriegt nicht einen Zettel, wo jetzt fünf Leute draufstehen, sondern das ist so eine komplette Fiebel.
Genau.
Wie so ein Lexikon.
Du hast mehrere Stimmen, die kannst du auch noch häufeln, auch Zwischenkandidaten.
Das heißt, jeder kriegt so ein komplettes Buch, damit er dann, mit wie viel Seiten, oder was?
Mit neun oder zwölf. Zetteln. Neun oder zwölf Seiten.
Und davon kreuze ich irgendwo auf drei Seiten irgendwas an.
Also kann man nochmal nachgucken, das ist einigermaßen gut erläutert bei diesem 24. Februar, die Propaganda, die sie dir machen.
Das ist aber im Prinzip schon mal neu. Also das hat so nicht stattgefunden vorher.
Na ja, es gab halt schon mal Fälle, wo du halt einfach vier oder fünf Wahlzettel bekommen hast, weil gleichzeitig noch irgendwie diese und jene und diese...
Aber es ist jetzt mehr als sonst.
Es ist mehr als sonst. Und das Wahlsystem ist halt schon komplexer, weil sie halt jetzt diese häufelnden Geschichten drin haben, also dass du mehrere Stimmen hast, die du verteilen kannst. Und das Problem ist halt, das war wieder so ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Die haben halt dieses komplexe Wahlsystem eingeführt, weil sie dachten, sie können... Also sie dachten, sie haben jetzt irgendwie elektronische Auszählhilfen, also können wir jetzt auch mal ein komplexes Wahlsystem einführen. De facto ist es aber so, dass die Auszählzeiten, die halt angegeben werden von Wegengeburt, zwei Wochen dauern, bis wir dann ein Ergebnis haben, ist halt Quatsch. Also es gibt halt eh nicht komplexes Wahlsystem, woanders im Bundesgebiet und da ist auch noch zwei, drei Tage ein Ergebnis da. Also es ist halt jetzt nicht so, dass es völlig irgendwie unmöglich wäre, da halt irgendwie zum Ergebnis zu kommen innerhalb so voller Zeit.
Naja, und das Problem ist ja, wenn sie tatsächlich ziehen, die Zettel, und aber den Stift nehmen, um damit ein vorläufiges Ergebnis rauszuhauen, dann haben sich eigentlich die Vorteile, die sich davon versprochen werden, natürlich nivelliert, weil sie ja trotzdem die Ehrenamtlichen brauchen, die halt diese komplexe, schwierige Wahlverfahren da auszählen. Klar, also damit haben sich in gewisser Weise halt die Vorteile erledigt und so richtig rechtfertigen können sie die Kosten dann nicht mehr, auch nicht für die vielen Laptops, die natürlich angeschafft werden müssen für jedes Wahllokal, wo jetzt die Stadt Hamburg argumentiert, ja, die müssen sowieso mal angeschafft werden, so im Wege der Ersatzbeschaffung nach dem Motto. Und die sind ja nicht so wirklich Kosten, die wir hier mit dazu rechnen. Aber man muss natürlich überlegen, dass jede Wahl in Hamburg dann wieder neue Zeit an Laptops bräuchte, weil die verabschieden...
Für jedes Wahllokal mindestens ein Computer.
Genau.
Das ist halt ein Problem. Sie können dann die Kosten vor dem Wälder nicht mehr so wirklich rechtfertigen, wenn der große versprochene Vorteil, nämlich das schnelle, super tolle Wahlergebnis, eben nicht mehr stattfindet.
Also es wurde auch schon gelästert, dass irgendwie der eigentliche Hintergrund sei, dass sie alle vier Jahre mal einen neuen Computer in den Ämtern haben wollten.
Man kann sich natürlich überlegen, wenn diese Wahlcomputer nach der Wahl als Bürocomputer irgendwie bei einer Behörde landen, können die natürlich nie wieder bei einer Wahl verwendet werden. Schon wegen einer Zertifizierung.
Die haben es auch nicht gesagt. Die wollten ja sozusagen immer neu beschaffen.
Dann müssen sie dann immer wieder neu beschaffen. Also man hat halt in Hamburg, wir haben ja schon mehrfach in Hamburg debattiert, mit dem Landeswahlleiter und auch mit den Leuten dort aus den Fraktionen. Ein paar von den grundsätzlichen Problemen sind denen schlicht nicht klar. Also das liegt natürlich daran, einfach wie man Computer Security sieht und dass man, wenn die Firmen immer wieder behaupten, das System sei sicher und die Angriffe, die gezeigt werden oder die theoretisch gezeigt werden, die könnten eben wieder durch prozedurale Sachen abgewendet werden. Na ja, dann wollen Politiker auch glauben, wenn sie einen Teil der Entscheidungen nämlich schon zu verantworten haben.
Also die Argumente, die jetzt halt gebracht werden gegen die verschiedenen Angriffe, die halt möglich sind, sind halt weitestgehend prozedural. Also die sagen halt, na ja, zum einen haben wir halt mit dieser Zertifizierung unser System toll sicher gemacht. Also wir haben jetzt hier einen sicheren Windows-Computer mit einem sicheren USB-Interface und so weiter und so fort. Und wir werden halt sicherstellen, dass da halt keine Manipulationen daran stattfinden, indem wir halt überall vier Augenprinzip machen. Das heißt also überall mindestens zwei Leute heransetzen, die halt alle kritischen Handlungen vornehmen. Und das ist sozusagen das Argument, was sie halt gerade versuchen, damit durchzukommen.
Na ja, es ist halt auch ein bisschen so ähnlich wie bei den NEDAPs. Also es gibt eigentlich auch nur ganz wenige Menschen, die eben wirklich wissen, wie dieses Software aussieht. Also sind eben wie bei den NEDAP wieder sehr, sehr wenige.
So, ich würde mal kurz eine kleine Pause machen, damit wir den Matebestand aufheben können, solange spielen wir mal hier immer ein bisschen Musik ein. So, weiter geht's mit Chaosradio Express live aus dem Wohnzimmer. Arbeitszimmer. Wohnzimmer klingt einfach romantischer. Jetzt hast du den Romantik-Effekt jetzt zerstört.
Ich bin die Regal voller Mischpulte.
Wir haben beim Wahlstift eine Sache vergessen, die ich noch erwähnen wollte. Für mich ist es noch mal ganz wichtig. Sie haben sich für die Briefwahlen in Hamburg auch noch eine spezielle Klinik ausgedacht. Sie werden nämlich die Stimmen der Briefwähler nachmalen mit dem digitalen Wahlstift, damit sie diese Stimmen von den Briefwahlen auch digital zählen können.
Nein.
ZB zwei Wahlhelfer werden die Briefumschläge aufmachen und einen Wahlstift nehmen und die Kreuze nachmalen. Das ist sozusagen Ihre Lösung für die Briefwahl. Das war der Punkt, wo selbst die SPD so ein bisschen so äh...
Na ja, und natürlich auch juristisch dann auch mal eine Frage, weil man natürlich juristisch dann sagen muss, okay, kann man das machen, das nachmalen? Ist da nicht eine Manipulation sowieso noch mal sehr einfach? Also, da ist noch mal einige juristische Fragen zu klären.
Ja, vor allem, dass sie das in einen Computer eintippen mussten, da kann ich ja gleich noch Verständnis für entwickeln, das machen sie wahrscheinlich auch bei den anderen Wahlen so, also zumindest mit den Prifahlen.
Die zusammen die zäten Ergebnisse machen.
Aber das dann so nachzuzeichnen, das ist ja wirklich malen nach zahlen.
Genau, wahlen nach zahlen an diesem Punkt.
Das Detail sollte man nicht vergessen. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie sich dabei einfach gar nichts gedacht. Also mir erscheint das immer so, solche Projekte sind am Anfang immer extrem tempting. So, ja super, wir automatisieren das. Und womit kann man das am besten automatisieren mit Computern? Und dann rennt man da so 50 Prozent rein, wie das fast bei jedem Projekt so ist. Man denkt sich immer so, ist ja alles ganz einfach, bis man dann auf die Details kommt und einfach irgendwann feststellt, dass man was Grundlegendes so falsch gemacht hat, dass man gar nicht hätte anfangen dürfen.
Ich würde das sogar wesentlich breiter sehen. Man kann das eigentlich jetzt über viele Jahre in der Literatur nachlesen, dass so computerisierte Wahlen in der Regel als zukunftsträchtig, als modern gesehen werden. Hier ist ja eine gewisse Big Picture dahinter, nämlich dass man wie selbstverständlich in der computerisierten Welt auch diese Wahlen computerisiert. Das gilt als modern und als, also Hamburg stellt sich ja auch immer noch so als Vorreiter hin. Hier muss auch ein gewisses Image gebrochen werden. Ich darf da etwa an Bill Gates Buch erinnern, der da schon darüber geschrieben hat, wie modern das sei und wie toll das wäre, wenn wir später mit unseren Handys wählen können. Oder jetzt die Meldung, die es vor wenigen Tagen gab, dass Korea per SMS wählt.
Das ist super, oder?
Das geht alles als super modern. Total hip.
Auch in der Schweiz übrigens. Da muss man gar nicht bis nach Korea schauen. Auch in der Schweiz gab es sowas schon. Was natürlich, da kann man fast noch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Sollte man eine Sendung zu SMS machen. Ich glaube, dass so eine Sendung zu SMS könnte augenöffnend wirken.
Eine Sendung zu SMS ist ein guter Plan.
Da würde ich gerne mitkommen. Ich würde nämlich diesen Suchtaspekt, der auch schon sehr gut untersucht ist, dann mal darstellen.
Ich würde ja noch mal...
Dieser Modernitätsaspekt ist ja auch bei den NEDAP-Geschichten sehr doll im Vordergrund. Dass gesagt wird, na, Computer sind ja hip und das wollen wir jetzt mal ganz dringend usw. Was halt total bizarr ist, weil diese NEDAP-Computer sind halt so richtiger 80s-Shit. Das ist halt so richtig so 68.000. Sieht aus wie ein alter Amiga von innen und ist de facto ein alter Amiga. Und das ist groß.
Also die ganze Hardware ist groß.
Das ist aber auch absichtlich damit... Meinst du jetzt nur die Elektronik oder meinst du...
Everything.
Na gut, ich meine, das Gerät als solches ist groß, weil es ja auch gleichzeitig eine Wahlkabine ist.
Ja, aber wenn du das aufklappst und hier die Innereien anguckst, sagst du, ach du meine Güte, das hab ich... Also ich persönlich, ich hab glaube ich auch noch nie so eine alte Hardware gesehen.
Das sah aus wie mein C64. Da konnte man auch mit einem Schraubenzieher die Chips raushebeln und so.
Als selber Technologiegeneration so. Und das ist halt so diese schöne Ironie daran, sodass halt irgendwie da so eine antiquierte Hardware als der letzte hippe Shit irgendwie gesehen wird.
Ja gut, diese neuen Wahlstifte, die erfüllen aber schon so einen gewissen Modernitätsanspruch.
Also Tippniskriterien erfüllen sie auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja alles, wir hätten das ja auch gerne hier so, funktioniert bloß nur auf Windows. Aber was kann man denn dagegen machen? Also ich meine, was fällt dir denn da so ein? Also warum ist dieses Wahlstift-Konzept jetzt besonders angreifbar?
Also es ist halt deswegen angreifbar, weil halt sehr viele komplexe Dinge gut gehen müssen. Also es fängt halt an dabei, dass das Pattern auf dem Papier korrekt sein muss. Also das heißt, das Pattern auf dem Papier muss man darauf vertrauen, dass ein Noto oder das richtige Pattern ausliefert, beziehungsweise der Hersteller.
Okay, aber das kann man ja vorher testen. Man kann ja so ein Heft nehmen.
Genau, du kannst halt eins von den Heften nehmen.
Okay, und davon ausgehen, dass alle Hefte gleich sind.
Genau, wobei man halt sagen muss, dass also ein Noto in seinen Guidelines auch schreibt, dass die Qualitätsanforderungen beim Druck von diesen Anoto-Seiten recht hoch sind. Also es ist halt so, dass es wohl sehr häufig vorkommt, dass einfach solche Anoto-Seiten Druckprobleme aufweisen. Wenn es ein bisschen verschmiert, verrotcht, der Winkel falsch ist, da gibt es allerhand Dinge, die dabei schief gehen können.
Man braucht eine gute Papierqualität und einen bestimmten Drucker dafür.
Also wenn man das jetzt selber drucken möchte.
Nein, auch der Hersteller. Wenn der Hersteller von diesen Wahlzetteln hingeht und diese Wahlzettel druckt, muss er eine signifikant verschärfte Qualitätskontrolle durchführen. Anoto sagt es halt so, eigentlich müsste man da eine Kamera über den Output hängen und von jeder Seite ein Sample checken, also mit dem Anoto Paper-Checker.
Ob das auch wirklich den gewünschten Effekt hatte?
Das ist nicht wirklich praktizierbar aufgrund der Menge.
Warum? Weil du halt jede einzelne Seite von irgendwie, kannst du ausrechnen, wie viel Wähler Hamburg hat, mal 9 oder mal 12.
Ich denke mir, dass jede Seite da über so ein Fließband läuft und dann hat man da so einen Zeilen-Scanner.
Nein, Zeilen-Scanner tut es halt nicht. Man braucht eine richtige Kamera und die muss auch auflösen sein in der richtigen Abstand.
Das müsste man schon stichprobenhalber tun. Das kostet natürlich auch nochmal Geld, wenn man es wirklich für alle machen wollte. Das ist aber eher ein Funktionalitäts- oder Robustheitsproblem hier.
Genau. Es gibt halt allerhand mögliche Angriffe gegen den Stift zum Beispiel.
Sagen wir nochmal, was alles überhaupt funktionieren muss.
Der Papier muss super sein. Der Stift muss perfekt funktionieren. Das heißt, die Kamera muss angehen. Wenn sozusagen die Mine aufs Papier kommt, muss die Kamera...
Der darf auch nicht kaputt gehen während der Wahl.
Genau. Der darf zum Beispiel nicht mit der Spitze...
Der wird aber den ganzen Tag von 1000 Leuten, die so ein Ding noch nie in der Hand haben...
Genau. Ich möchte das nochmal vorheben. Da ist nämlich auch nochmal dieser Wähler dabei. Der Wähler kann damit Schindluder treiben. Er kann das absichtlich kaputt machen. Er kann seinen eigenen Stift nehmen. Er kann da eine Klarsichtfolie unterlegen. Da ist noch diese menschliche Komponente hinter einer Wand, weil er nicht beobachtet wird, was er mit dem Stift tut.
Das heißt, wenn man dahingeht und vorne einfach den Nippel abschneidet und sagt, ich habe gewählt, dann haben die da erstmal ein Problem. Oder die Kamera zuklebt oder mit einem Edding drauf malt.
Oder sein eigener mitbringt und die merken das, aber er rennt mit dem anderen weg.
Den tauscht. Also einfach so ein Logitech-Tralala-Pen. Denen die denn genauso aus?
Gar nicht mal, dass er damit eine Wahl manipuliert. Er könnte einfach signifikant stören. Oder wenn sich einfach nur 10 Prozent der Leute entschließen, nö, ich will meinen Mont Blanc. Was ist denn dann? Was machen die denn, die Leute in Hamburg?
Naja, ich denke mal, was passiert denn dann? Dann wird der Stift. Also angenommen kommt so der Schiffsbesitzer irgendwie, der schon immer gewählt hat, kommt dann morgens 8.30 da rein oder 9.30, nimmt seinen Mont Blanc. Moin. Ich weder mal, nicht? So, dann schickt er seinen Mont Blanc, wie er es immer gemacht hat, denkt sich gar nichts dabei, weil...
Gebt den Stift zurück.
Schön, dass sie mir den Stift gegeben haben, aber ich habe ja meinen eigenen, danke.
Genau, dann hat er nicht gewählt.
Und dann gibt er diesen Wahlstifter ab, dann stecken die da rein und dann sagt er, piep, keine Stimme.
Nee, das darf er nicht.
Wie, das darf er nicht?
Also wenn du den Stifter reinsteckst, darf er keinerlei äußere Anzeichen darüber, ob du irgendwas angekreuzt hast oder was du angekreuzt hast, von sich geben.
Das ist ein Wahlgeheimnis, Stimmenthaltung.
Genau.
Das heißt, er weiß gar nicht, dass er nicht gewählt hat.
Es geht ja so, dass einige der Wahllokale ausgezählt werden. Stichformatisch.
17 Stück.
Von den 3.000, glaube ich.
Weiß man vorher welche?
Nee. Und diese Abweichung müsste dann ja zwangsläufig zutage treten. Aber die Entscheidung, die Hamburg getroffen hat, ist uns egal. Klar, da kann eine Abweichung sein.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt in jedes Wahllokal morgens jemand reingeht und mit einem Edding diese Kamera zumalt, dann merken die das gar nicht, weil der Stift nichts gezählt hat.
Vielleicht machen sie zwischendurch noch einen Test, dass sie mit dem Stift noch mal einen Test-Wahlzettel ankreuzen.
Das würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie nicht zwischendurch mehrere Stifte pro Wahllokal haben.
Aber sie prüfen auch nicht jedes Mal nach jedem einzelnen Wahlvorgang den Test.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall mit Sonntag keine signifikanten Stimmen vernichten.
Und zwar ohne, dass man weiß, wessen.
Allerdings nur die elektronische Stimme. Der Wähler hätte, sofern er das Papier ankreuzt, eine gültige Stimme abgegeben.
Solange der Kuli noch funktioniert. Der Kuli ist aber nicht elektronisch.
Oh, die Mine könnte alle gehen?
Na die Mine könnte alle gehen, aber gut, dann sagt er wieder, mein Minius, alle, gib mir mal eine neue Mine.
Oder er zückt seinen eigenen Stift und macht...
Oder er zückt halt seinen Stift und macht seinen Kreuz, weistet seine Stimme.
Das heißt aber, man kreuzt irgendwo an, dann denkt der Stift schon, es ist schon gewählt worden, obwohl gar keine Farbe auf dem Papier ist. Und dann kriegt man eine neue Mine eingesetzt, oder was?
Na, wäre ja auch eine Klarsichtfolie so. Also wenn du etwa eine Klarsichtfolie hinlegst, kreuzmachst, dann zählt dir der Stift an der Stelle, wo du angekreuzt hast, aber auf dem Zettel wäre ja nichts. Auch das ist eine Abweichung. Jetzt im anderen, andersrum. Klar, ist ja auch möglich.
Also die... Also, sozusagen... Also de facto, was halt passiert ist, um uns sozusagen so ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, dem Wähler wird halt suggeriert, dass er eine Papierwahl durchführt. Aber de facto drückt er einen Knopf auf einem Computer, und zwar unscharf. So, also er wird Kreuzkanner daneben liegen. Aber de facto findet eine Computerwahl statt. Also es wird halt nichts weiter gemacht als das Knöpfchendrücken auf dem Neder durch Kreuzchenmachen auf dem Knopf auf dem Papier substituiert. Das ist genauer, was da passiert.
Ja, und dazu kommt eigentlich noch, dass der Wähler nicht nur Fehler machen kann, von denen er vielleicht gar nicht weiß, dass es Fehler sind im Sinne von einer Abgabe der Stimme, sondern er kann natürlich auch einfach eingreifen in diesen Prozess. Da er ja quasi den Sensor, der diese Stimmen aufzeichnet, in der Hand hält. Also er kann das absichtlich und natürlich auch unbewusst unabsichtlich tun.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn halt diese Stifte runterfallen, wenn man so die Annotussupportforen liest, wenn der Stift genau auf die Spitze fällt, dann geht halt gerne mal der Drucksensor kaputt.
Kann ja auch mal passieren. Man muss ja nicht immer denken, dass der wieder da irgendwie nicht mitmachen will.
Und schon zählt ja halt keine Stimme mehr, weil die Kamera nicht angeht oder permanent an ist und der Stift halt sagt, ist irgendwas schief.
Und im Prinzip, also wir wissen halt auch nicht genau, wie die Funktionalitäts- und Robustzeitstests der PTB ablaufen. Weil auch hier wird ja wieder nur der Endbericht veröffentlicht. Also keine Ahnung, inwieweit dort die Robustzeit und so gecheckt wird.
Also auf jeden 29,90 Euro Stuhl von IKEA wird 50.000 Mal draufgehauen. Aber so ein Stift, der irgendwie über die Delegation von Macht entscheidet, wird noch nicht mal angefasst.
Also jedenfalls wird dann, na ja, ich schätze mal, die werden ihn schon testen. Die Frage ist halt nur, ob sie halt irgendwie da zu ehrlichen Ergebnissen kommen. Oder habe ich so gewisse Zweifel.
Mal sehen, also es könnte ja immer noch sein, dass die PTB sagt, das könnte passieren. Aber wir trauen der PTB in diesem Punkt nicht mehr allzu viel zu.
Was mir auch noch so ein bisschen Sorgen macht, ist ja die Tatsache, dass in dem Moment, wo die Stimme den, oder sagen wir mal, der Kreuzigungsvorgang, diesen Stift verlassen hat, dann befindet sich ja diese gezählte Stimme in diesem Windows-Computer.
Genau, aus Redundanzgründen wird sie auf einem externen USB-Stick und im Computer selbst gespeichert.
Also sie haben da so einen Stick dran.
Also sozusagen wird zweimal gespeichert wegen der Sicherheit.
Man kann ja sein, dass die Platte crasht.
In randomisierter Reihenfolge. Da haben sie auch schon dran gedacht. Das ist halt eine Datenbank. Also das System ist halt so, das gibt halt einen, also vom Layering her, du hast halt diesen USB-Treiber, der sitzt oberhalb der Windows-USB-Infrastruktur. Daran registriert sich der Stift als USB-Device. Dann wird über dieses proprietäre Protokoll werden die Striche da rausgelutscht aus dem Stift. Aus den Strichen wird ein Vektor-File zusammengesetzt. Dieses Vektor-File geht in ein Stück Software, das versucht, die Stimme zu identifizieren, die sozusagen mit diesem Kreuz verbunden ist. Dann wird das Vektor-File zusammen mit der Identifizierungsmarkierung, was jetzt für eine Stimme war, in eine Datenbank geschrieben, randomisiert. Diese Datenbank läuft parallel auf dem USB-Stick und auf dem Windows-Computer.
Also wird sozusagen in zwei reingeschrieben.
Also in zwei gespiegelte Datenbanken geschrieben. Und am Wahlende, da gibt es noch so ein Confidence-Level, wie überzeugt die Software ist, dass sie weiß, wo das Kreuz ist. Am Wahlende wird dann ein Query auf die Datenbank gemacht. Dann werden alle rausgedumpt, die klar sind. Dann wird ein Ergebnis dafür kalkuliert. Dann bleiben irgendwie noch 20 übrig.
Von denen die Software sagt, dass sie klar sind.
Genau. Die Software-Meinung ist, sie weiß, was gewählt wurde. Und dann bleibt ein Stapel übrig. Die werden auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt, den Wahlhelfern. Und die sagen dann, okay, das war wohl das oder das war wohl das. Oder die sind ungültig, weil sie nicht wissen, was das ist. Genau. Wenn sie nicht auf Skip drücken, dann wird das ungültig erklärt.
Auf dem Laptop-Bildschirm wird das alles angezeigt. Das heißt, diese Wahlhelfer ist irgendwo definiert, wie viele das dann entscheiden müssen.
Ein Vier-Augen-Prinzip gibt es auf jeden Fall. Aber da sind auch mehrere Menschen.
Ich habe noch keinen Raum, wo nicht so viele sind. Ist das dann in dem Moment, wo die Stimme gezählt wird?
In dem Moment, wo die Auszählung erfolgt, also nach 18 Uhr.
Sonst könnten sie ja genau wissen, was der weder eben gesehen hat.
Das heißt, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt denken sie, in zwei Minuten können wir nach Hause gehen. Aber dann sagt der irgendwie, wir haben aber jetzt hier 14.000 Stimmen, die alle schlecht entscheiden.
1.500 pro Wahlokal.
So einen fiesen Hack würden wir uns aber nicht ausdenken.
Na gut, aber es kann ja sein, dass das Gerät nun tatsächlich kaputt ist. Es fängt ja nicht an zu leuchten, wenn es kaputt ist.
Also in bestimmten Fehlerfällen fängt es schon an zu leuchten, aber das sind halt schwerwiegende.
Ja gut, aber das ist auf jeden Fall genug Szenarien jetzt, nach dem, was du mir da geschildert hast, vorstellbar, wo das sehr wohl sein, also zumindest nicht vollständig auszuschließen ist, dass am Ende eine große Zahl vielleicht sogar vorgelegt wird.
Wir müssen da vielleicht noch hinzufügen, dass wir noch ein paar mehr Ideen haben, aber wie Frank das neulich so schön formuliert hat, es ist ja eigentlich so, nicht wir müssen denen beweisen, dass der Stift unsicher ist, sondern die müssen uns beweisen, dass der sicher ist. Und das haben sie mal schlicht nicht gemacht.
Aber ich merke schon, wenn man erst mal nur anfängt, darüber nachzudenken, wo man den irgendwie so überall, da man dann ja auch wirklich im Zugriff hat. Ich meine, bei diesem ganzen NEDAP-Computer war das immer so dieses, na ja, aber es kommt ja keiner ran. Und hier wird das Gerät sozusagen jedem in die Hand gedrückt und man darf sich dann eine Minute lang in einem dunklen Raum... Jeder Hacker darf sich da mal zwei Minuten dran versuchen.
Wir könnten alle nach Hamburg umziehen.
Ja, und ich meine, das ausgerechnet auch noch in Hamburg, der Stadt, in der der CCC groß geworden ist. Also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben.
Und mit gutem Grund. Also da hätten sie vielleicht mal früher ein paar unabhängige Experten heranziehen sollen. Also ich meine, wir haben ziemlich viele Universitäten an dieser Uni. Wir haben einen sehr willigen Chaos-Computer-Club, der da gerne auch mal vorher seine Meinung gesagt hätte. Aber mit der Bewilligung des Geldes und dem Zeitdruck sind sie jetzt in so einer blöden Klemme, dass sie sich eigentlich, egal wie, vor den Wählern nur noch blamieren können.
Also der Zeitplan, den sie hatten, sozusagen ohne Raum für irgendwelche Probleme, war halt schon sehr ambitioniert. Also dieses Schutzprofil ist erst im März zur CeBIT halt zertifiziert worden. Das heißt also, da konnte halt diese Common Criteria-Erprüfung überhaupt anfangen. Und soweit ich weiß, ist bisher kein anderes, und es sollte jetzt im Oktober fertig sein. Und soweit ich weiß, ist bisher kein anderes Produkt in dieser Geschwindigkeit, also von dieser Komplexität vor allen Dingen, in dieser Geschwindigkeit zertifiziert worden. Das heißt, es ist ein sehr, sehr ambitionierter Zeitplan.
Ich will das Schutzprofil nicht so gerne in den Mittelpunkt drücken, weil es ist von vornherein noch sehr, sehr umstrittend. Nicht nur unter uns, sondern auch an der Wissenschaft. Ob diese Schutzprofil irgendeinen Sinn macht für so eine...
Ob Common-Criteria Sinn macht für so eine Geschichte.
Der Common-Criteria-Prozess halt Sinn macht für so eine Wahlcomputer-Geschichte. Was mich noch interessiert ist, angenommen jetzt ist alles super. Also kein Wahlstift hat irgendwelche Funktionsschwächen. Niemand ist auf die Idee gekommen, einen Edding zu benutzen. Niemand hat vor eine Mauer zu bauen. Und dieser Windows-Computer schreibt in beide Datenbanken das Richtige rein. So, man hat da irgendwie noch einen Backup. Wie kommt denn jetzt die Stimme dann eigentlich... Also wie wird denn alles zusammengezählt? Weiß man das?
Ja, die werden auf zwei verschiedene USB-Sticks gespeichert. Und dann gibt es ein Protokoll, wo dann per Hand das Computerergebnis eingestragen wird. Dann wird der USB-Stick da rangeheftet.
Also vom Bildschirm auf Papier übertragen.
Genau. Es gibt sogar einen Drucker. Es gibt einen Drucker, also wird er halt ausgedruckt.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt müssen dann wahrscheinlich die Wahlhelfer sagen, dass nach ihrer Beobachtung die Elektronen in die richtige Richtung geflogen sind.
Genau, so, dass es also keiner Mangietfeldumkehr gab unter der gleichen Dinge. Was sind das Insekten hier in der Zunge?
Das ist eine Vorsichtsmaßnahme.
Wegen der Sicherheit.
Wenn ich immer was zum Debuggen habe.
Die zertifizieren halt zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass irgendwie alles schön ist. Und stempeln und signieren halt irgendwie ihren heiligen Ausdruck da. Und klemmen dann den ultraheiligen OSB-Stick daran. Und der geht dann halt in die Zentrale. In der Zentrale wird dann der OSB-Stick ausgelesen. Wird nochmal kurz geguckt, ob das Ergebnis aus dem OSB-Stick mit dem auf dem Zettel übereinstimmt. Hoffentlich. Sonst sagen sie, dass es passiert. Bei NEDAP zum Beispiel ist das in der Regel nicht der Fall.
Also wir wissen, dass die Prozeduren, wie sie geplant sind, halt auch nicht immer durchgeführt werden.
Die werden halt de facto nicht eingehaltener. Und dann geht das halt alles in die große, heilige Software der Statistik Nord. Und die ermittelt dann ein Wahlergebnis.
Was ist das?
Das ist halt so ein Rechenzentrum, wo halt irgendwie Statistiken berechnet werden.
Das gehört dem Land?
Ich denke, es ist eine Landestochter oder vielleicht ist es auch so ein Public-Private-Partnership. Aber keine Ahnung, ich weiß es überhaupt nicht. So, und aus dieser Software fällt dann haltet irgendwie ein Ergebnis.
Und natürlich sind auch dort die Mitarbeiter Security-checked. Nicht, dass du glaubst, da würden irgendwie willfährige Helfershelfer arbeiten. Die sind alle sicherheitsgeprüft. Das ist ja auch jetzt noch mal fünfmal betont worden.
Genau, es sind halt alle sicherheitsüberprüfte Helfershelfer hier.
Sicherheitsüberprüft.
Das heißt, sie haben alle keine Verwandten in Saudi-Arabien.
Die haben eine Clearance, die wir nie kriegen.
Echt?
Also, ich bin weiblich, aber ihr kriegt die nie.
Wir sind böse stinkende Hacker.
Ihr seid stinkende Hacker.
Jaja, wir. Vier Männer, vier beiden. Also eigentlich nur Frank und ich. Die anderen nicht. So, was mich ja noch mal interessieren würde. Warte mal. Wahlstift? Wir haben es jetzt. Das haben wir schon vergessen? Bestimmt. Aber am 9. November gibt es da eine Entscheidung oder zumindest heißt es?
November gibt es eine Anhörung.
Eine Anhörung?
Genau.
Vom? Wer? Hört wie?
Vom Verfassungsausschuss des Senats. Und danach setzt sich dann dieser Ausschuss nochmal zusammen und trifft eine abschließende Entscheidung.
Weil sie müssen ja jetzt auch.
Verfassungsausschuss.
Genau, weil halt eine verfassungsändernde, sozusagen diese Wahlgesetzänderung ist halt substanziell. Also das ist halt so, dass sie wirklich eine richtige Mehrheit dafür brauchen. Also das geht halt nicht mit mal eh mal durchwinken.
Das heißt, wenn dieser Ausschuss sagt, das ist alles prima, danach muss noch der Landtag eine Verfassungsänderung sozusagen.
Es gibt ja nun bloß drei Fraktionen in Hamburg. Da gibt es halt nur CDU, SPD und die grüne Alternativliste. Und sie wollen aber auch eine große Mehrheit. Sie wollen eine Zustimmung möglichst aller Fraktionen.
Wie viel Prozent brauchen sie denn für eine Verfassungsänderung?
Also sie brauchen glaube ich technisch gesehen, naja es ist sozusagen, es hat Verfassungsänderungen einen Rang, aber es ist keine Verfassungsänderung, soweit gibt es Überblicke. Also de facto brauchen sie dann zwei Drittel Mehrheit.
Aber sie wollen auch gerne Konsens.
Also sie wollen halt gerne Konsens. Also es ist halt so, dass sowohl CDU als SPD gesagt haben, dass sie, wenn es halt schwerwiegende Bedenken verbleiben, dann wollen sie es lieber nicht machen, weil irgendwie haben sie dann doch so ein bisschen Schiss, dass sie sich da irgendwie wieder eintreten.
Die Grünen haben aber schon mal schwerwiegende Bedenken.
Ja, jetzt aber beschlossen haben diese digitale Wahlstift-System schon alle Fraktionen. Also genickt haben sie erstmal alle. Deswegen die Peinlichkeit eigentlich für alle gleiches.
Und das, obwohl auf dem Grünen-Parteitag da eine Abstimmung war über Wahlcomputer?
Die Grünen haben sich jetzt sozusagen besonnen und gesagt, okay, es ist vielleicht besser, einen Fehler einzugestehen und ihn zu korrigieren als jetzt halt irgendwie, also was ja eine löbliche Abweichung von irgendwie im sonstigen politischen Verhalten ist. Aber ja, sich sozusagen halt auf die richtige Seite zu schlagen und zu versuchen, halt da noch die Debakel zu verändern.
Also die anderen beiden Fraktionen haben eigentlich unisono verlautbart, dass sie hoffen, dass am 9. November einfach nur alle Bedenken ausgeräumt werden können. Da sind wir natürlich schon gespannt.
Das war halt sozusagen die öffentliche Verlautbarung hinter den Kulissen, sieht halt ein bisschen anders aus, aber da können wir jetzt gerade noch nicht so viel sagen.
Und glaubst du, dass dieser Verfassungsausschuss das auch so sieht, dass im Prinzip bewiesen werden muss, dass da keine Zweifel dran sind? Oder warten sie eigentlich eher darauf, dass jemand nochmal mit ein paar schlechten Nachrichten kommt und zeigt, wie man das alles kaputt machen kann?
Das ist unklar. Also vermarkert nicht zu sagen.
Also es ist sicherlich, man muss sehen, dass da wirklich eine große Koalition, nämlich alle Fraktionen, beschlossen haben, das zu machen. Da ist eine Menge Geld geflossen. Wir haben jetzt die Details schon ein bisschen erzählt. Vermutlich hoffen die tatsächlich, dass sie das wieder ausräumen können und mit ihrem System weiter machen können. Aber zumindest die Firma, die die Software herstellt, die hat doch auch schon mehrfach jetzt unter der Hand gesagt, dass sie sich damit abfinden könnten, wenn es eine reine Zählhilfe wäre. Wie sie dann natürlich den finanziellen Verlust ihren Weden erklären, das bleibt den Parteien überlassen.
Da ist so 5 Millionen in Hamburg nicht so ein Problem.
Das ist schon ein bisschen mehr. Laptops musst du ja auch mit rechnen.
Ja, die müssen doch eben die Verwaltung haben wir gelernt.
Aber die hätten sie vielleicht sonst nicht gekriegt.
Also interessant, das ist schon ein bisschen teurer.
Es sind halt vier Spielplätze weniger. Das werden sie schon verkraften.
Ja, oder lass mich überlegen. Neun Professoren? Also wenn wir jetzt die Universitäten sehen, oder vielleicht sagen wir mal 80 Lehrer? Lass mich nachdenken. Und vielleicht haben wir dann kein Geld, noch irgendein Mühlenberger Loch zuzuschieben, wenn wir noch eins übrig haben. Das habe ich jetzt nur nicht.
Da gehören ja auch noch Mitarbeiter dazu.
Ach so, also du hast mich schwer aus der Brille gerettet.
So ist die Situation in Hamburg mit dem Wahlstift. Beunregende Neuigkeiten. Wir sind alle gespannt, wie das jetzt so weitergehen wird. Am 9. November sind wir hoffentlich schlauer. Auf jeden Fall sehr wertvoll, sich diese Diskussion anzuschauen. Wer von euch jetzt hier bis hier hindurch gehört hat, kann ja auch nur noch mal darauf hinweisen, macht euch mal schlau generell über Wahlcomputer, wenn das noch ein neues Thema für euch ist. Es gibt da auch eine extensive Ressource. Zum Beispiel bei uns im Berliner CCC-Wiki. Die Links findet ihr alle hier in den Notizen zu der Sendung auf der Webseite oder auch in der Datei.
Vielleicht sollten wir da auch mal einen Aufruf machen. Dieser Wahlstift hat einfach ein hohes Hackvalue. Und in gewisser Weise, wir haben das auch schon gemerkt in den letzten Monaten, seit wir die Hardware da so haben, es hat auch einen gewissen Charme daran zu hacken. Einfach weil da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten. Und wer da jetzt mal Lust zu hat, und vielleicht irgendwie die 100 Euro auf Tasche und sich diese Hardware, die man ja auch so benutzen kann, die ist ja nicht unpraktisch.
Gibt es denn eigentlich da Open Source-Treiber für? Das wäre vielleicht gleich nochmal ein Grund.
Es gibt halt so Ansätze, aber noch nichts richtig Komplettes.
120 Euro hast du gesagt. Also schon noch eine überschaubare Investition.
Genau, also der Hack-Value ist auf jeden Fall eine Größenordnung von 10 Kinokarten. Das kann man schon so einschätzen. Also ist halt, wenn man so...
Die würdest du jetzt spendieren, wenn da jemand...
Nee, man rechnet ja sozusagen, wie viel gibt man so aus. Reverse-Engineering hat ja immer so einen gewissen Kostenfaktor. Achso, ich verstehe, was du meinst. Man hat länger Spaß damit, als wenn man irgendwie 12 Kinokarten hat.
Den ersten hat es auch Spaß gemacht, die mal aufzuschrauben, ein paar Leute zusammenzusetzen und einfach die Hardware analysiert. Und die guckt, was passiert, wenn man jetzt die USB-Verbindung anmacht. Dann guckt man, ob wir kniffen können. Das ist lustig.
Genau, das Ding hat auch JTAG. Man kann die Firmware auslesen.
JTAG ist der Standard-Adapter für elektronische Analyse.
Genau, zum Testen von Elektronik. Der USB-Treiber sieht auch einigermaßen vielversprechend aus. Die Stifte sprechen sogar HTTP über IP, wenn man sie richtig überredet.
Ach, da ist ein Web-Server drauf, oder wie?
Nein, die sprechen HTTP. Sie können an einem HTTP-Server Dinge schicken, z.B. Notes usw. Laut der Analyse der Firmware gibt es da eine extensive Test- und Debug-Menüs, wo man herausfinden kann, wie die angesteuert werden. Es gibt da jede Menge Spiel- und Spaß-Kraft.
Geneigte Hacker integrieren wir auch gerne zum gemeinsamen Spielen.
Fallen dir jetzt auch noch ein paar Hack-Ziele ein, ein paar konkrete, wo man mal forschen könnte?
Eine komplette Firmware-Analyse wäre sicher hilfreich. Da sind wir noch nicht komplett durch.
Das ist auch relativ oft.
Es ist einigermaßen hart, aber es ist ein Arm da drin. Da läuft ein Arm-Prozessor auf dem Ding. Das ist durchaus machbar.
Wir werden das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr machen vom 9. Jahrhundert, weil wir uns alle Dinge zu tun haben.
Das ist sicherlich nicht die Mehrzahl unserer Hörer, aber es gibt natürlich schon sehr gute Reverse-Ingenierer da draußen. Und ein Arm-Prozessor ist ja jetzt auch nichts Unpopuläres. Steckt nahezu in jedem modernen elektronischen Gerät.
Kann man auch später noch brauchen?
Die Firmware-Update-Folds kann man runterladen, zum Beispiel bei Logitech. Also man muss es nicht zwingend bei JTEC rauspupeln. Die sind eigentlich so ein bisschen kruden Format. Da muss man sich ein bisschen mit den Formaten beschäftigen.
Wie kann man denn diese Software eigentlich aktualisieren auf dem Stift?
Es gibt ein Software-Aktualisierungssystem, wo dann halt ein neues Firmware-Fall da reingeblasen wird. Das kommt halt in so einen spezifischen Format. Und wird da über die USB-Schnittstelle reingetan.
Und wie sichert sich dieser Stift davor, aktualisiert zu werden?
Also es gibt da Hinweise darauf, dass es da so ein bisschen Signature-Fu gibt. Also nach dem, was wir so gesehen haben.
Wir brauchen hier eigentlich nicht spekulieren.
Aber wir wissen es halt schlicht noch nicht im Detail.
Sie haben uns ja schließlich den tatsächlichen Wahlstift nicht geben wollen.
Okay, aber es ist schon so, dass diese Geräte an sich, die auf dem Markt sind, in der Regel auch über diese USB-Schnittstelle eine neue Software bekommen. Okay, das ist ja schon mal eine Aussage. Und man braucht ja, im Chat sind es, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Leute da jetzt mithören. Uns hören jetzt ist ja hier eine experimentelle Chaosradio Express-Sendung. Muss ich vielleicht auch noch mal explizit erwähnen. Wir haben hier mal das Ganze neben der Aufzeichnung auch noch live gemacht. Dann gibt es zwar, wie schon beim letzten Mal, als Sie es getestet haben, ein paar technische Probleme, aber im Prinzip läuft 70 Leute hören uns jetzt geradezu.
Na ja, also bei den 70 müssen noch eigentlich also mindestens 35 dabei sein, die da gerne mal mithaken wollen.
Genau, die Jetik im Schlaf sprechen und einen Niederpro schon gebotet haben.
Genau, da können wir bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht noch etwas anderes erwähnen. Nur für den Fall, dass unter den 70 Hörern oder unter den Leuten, die später den Podcast holen, Leute dabei sind, die sich beteiligt haben an der Wahlcomputerspenden-Kampagne.
Genau, da wollen wir noch mal...
Wir haben, glaube ich, versäumt als CCC jemals zu sagen, dass wir uns allerherzlich bedanken wollen und dass wir auch dabei sind, diese Gelder echt sinnvoll einzusetzen und auch auf der juristischen Ebene einzusetzen. Es sind auf jeden Fall über 6000 Euro zusammengekommen. Und davon werden wir zumindest einen Teil auch in die juristische Problematik stecken, weil wir jetzt einen Anwalt gefunden haben, der uns da helfen wird. Weil wir wollen auch jetzt in Hessen, wo ja wieder NEDAP anstehen, da weiter vorgehen.
Und auch mal so Geräte kaufen zum Auseinanderschrauben.
Genau.
NEDAPs sind vielleicht jetzt ja preiswerte zu haben.
Vielleicht haben ja auch noch ein paar da den Brand überlebt, wer weiß.
Was sollen sie mit den 1000 oder 200 machen?
Ab auf Ebay, verschmorte Wahlcomputer.
Jetzt wollen sie ja die holländischen Essener mit diesen komischen Drucker-Ranflanschungen nachrüsten.
Das ist bestimmt dann nur ein Prototyp. Nachher ist es ganz schick.
Das sieht aus wie, als wäre alles ganz toll.
Das würde ja auch passen zu ihrem uralt-Hardware.
Da sieht man diese Klotzer, da sieht man sowas. Na ja, lassen wir das.
Wir haben uns jetzt hier mal offiziell dafür bedankt, wie viele Leute sich mit kleinen Beträgen da beteiligt haben. Und dass wir am Ende mit der Kohle vielleicht am Ende so gut wie in Holland Erfolg haben.
Genau, denn das mit den Wahlcomputern, dieser Spuk muss auch in Deutschland ein Ende haben. Weil das alles nicht gut ist. Ja, ich denke, jetzt haben wir es, wahr?
Wir haben noch eine Menge Themen vergessen, aber wir...
Wir haben noch eine Menge erzählt, aber ich denke, wir werden hier auch noch mal drauf zurückkommen, wenn die Ereignisse sich etwas verdichtet haben. Und dann können wir auch mal sehen, was bei den ganzen Hackereien vielleicht rausgekommen ist. Ja, ich bedanke mich, Frank, Constanze, wieder ein sehr nettes Gespräch. Und ich bedanke mich auch noch mal hier bei den Leuten, die hier das Streaming immer wieder ermöglichen, bei jeder Chaosradio-Sendung und jetzt auch bei Chaosradio Express. Mal schauen, ob wir das noch mal so stabil hinbekommen, dass wir das jetzt zum regelmäßigen Service machen können. Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr lustig, das auch interaktiv mit dem Chat zu machen.
Auch ohne Vinyl-Effekt dieses Mal?
Auch ohne Vinyl-Effekt. Ja, Audiotechnologie, wenn sie digital wird, kann ich dir sagen, das ist eher so im Bereich Wahlcomputersichern. Also das ist ja nicht alles so einfach, nicht? Da schätzt man noch so das normale analoge Kabel. Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass ich das so mal nochmal sage.
Ich gucke früher so die ersten Rundfunk-Sendungen.
Entschuldigung, mir hat das Franz jetzt hier echt aus, oder?
Ja, aber so kommt mir das auch ein bisschen vor.
Oh, jetzt werdet ihr euch die alten Geschichten erzählen, wie bitter euch, ja?
Das ist wie Albert Einstein hier bei der Funk-Ausstellung.
Vielleicht könnte mir jemand im Chat mal sagen, dass die Männer jetzt aufhören sollen.
Dummes Zeug zu reden. Okay, dann war's das. Wir sagen alle ordentlich Tschüss. Und bis zum nächsten Mal bei Chaosradio Express.